cela s'inscrit dans l'eure dans un
rassemblement on a du mal à comprendre
l'idée d'une candidature communiste je
ne souhaite pas que dès maintenant on
nous dise et bien vous n'avez pas le
droit de présenter votre candidature de
quel droit aujourd'hui on pourrait dire
ça laissez les français décider oui le
parti communiste français souhaitent
pouvoir incarner l'alternative le
changement l'espoir
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bonsoir à tous bienvenue pour deux
heures d'émission nous décrypterons
comme chaque soir du lundi au jeudi
l'essentiel de l'information avec nos
invités et nos reporters sur le terrain
tout de suite voici les grands titres de
l'actualité de ce lundi 19 avril à une
rencontre avec des policiers à
montpellier une grande interview au
figaro emmanuel macron fixe un nouveau
cap sécuritaire un an de la
présidentielle séminaire gouvernemental
sur la sécurité beauvau de la sécurité
le chef de l'état muscle sa politique et
promet plus de bleus sur le terrain
si emmanuel macron accélère est ce parce
que le président échoué sur la sécurité
ce sera l'objet de notre face à face au
pakistan les onze policiers pris en
otage hier ont été libérées tôt ce matin
des communautés religieuses appelle à
une grève générale dans le pays
à la manoeuvre un parti islamiste
radical qui protestent contre le droit
de caricaturer les religions en france
le premier ministre appelle les
militants anti france à revenir au calme
le quai d'orsay a rappelé quinze de ses
diplomates et demande à ses
ressortissants de quitter le pays
[Musique]
aux etats unis à présent le procès
chauvine touche à sa fin aujourd'hui
débute le réquisitoire de l'accusation
et la plaidoirie de la défense
l'ex policier accusé d'avoir tué georgia
fleurs et de refuse toujours de
témoigner le jugement est attendu à la
fin du mois
[Musique]
emmanuel macron s'est donc rendu à
montpellier aujourd'hui au programme une
visite de l'hôtel de police pour mesurer
les effets de la politique de sécurité
au quotidien
le chef de l'état qui en a profité pour
rassurer les forces de l'ordre une
visite qui intervient au lendemain de
son entretien au figaro dans lequel il
fait le point sur sa politique de
sécurité
quentin mauclair les manifs
diffusion de ce sujet voilà est-ce qu'on
peut m'indiquer ce qui se passe voilà
merci on remettait ce sujet où ça ne
fonctionne pas merci de me le dire voilà
pour en parler donc nous sommes avec un
stanislas godon délégué général alliance
police
bonsoir stanislas godon merci d'être
avec nous en direct sur arte france on
n'a pas eu la chance malheureusement de
devoir
un petit peu la teneur de ce que nous
disait emmanuel macron ce matin dans le
figaro et la teneur de sa visite à
montpellier mais en gros le président
tente de défendre son bilan sur la
sécurité
vous avez évidemment lui en ces colonnes
du figaro vous avez suivi cette visite
est ce que vous vous avez été convaincu
ben tout d'abord on a un peu
l'impression quand même qu'il ya une
campagne électorale qui est en train de
s'annoncer où il ya un affichage de
communication en temps de renouer aussi
le dialogue avec je dirais l'univers de
la police nationale parce que il ya eu
des déclarations par le passé qui ont
profondément heurté la maison police et
les collègues sur le terrain n'avait
absolument pas apprécié le contrôle au
faciès des violences policières qui qui
avait jeté un peu l'opprobre sur le
travail de mes collègues au quotidien
alors là et je dirais cet art conquête
pas républicaine mais la reconquête dans
l'univers de la police avec un bilan
avec des annonces aussi sur ce qui
devrait être fait bon nous on attend
surtout des actes parce que vous savez
que les policiers on a eu beaucoup de
déclarations politiques
on nous a un jour adoubée on nous a
demandés on nous a dit féliciter parce
qu'on avait tenu à bout de bras la
république et on avait préservé la
république dans le cadre des
manifestations de gilet jaune dans la
lutte contre le terrorisme
et puis chaque fois qu'il ya eu des
événements un peu compliqué eh ben tout
de suite on a jeté un peu les policiers
en pâture et puis c'était la présomption
de culpabilité
donc non il faut là qui est un soutien
de tous les instants et qui plus est
aujourd'hui ans et maman très compliqué
pour les policiers je rappelle que tous
les jours nous avons des actes de
violences urbaines à l'encontre des
policiers
tous les jours c'est du cocktail molotov
ces deux des gènes mortiers d'artifice
et des insultes
c'est ça la réalité du policier au
quotidien aujourd'hui et je crois que
dans le débat qu'il ya sur la sécurité
on ne pourra pas dissocier à la fois
l'univers de la police l'univers
d'insécurité et
vert de la justice parce que les deux
doivent marcher sur leurs deux jambes
stanislas godon clairement vous dites
voilà on s'est sentis par moments
totalement abandonné 1
c'est en substance l'idée que vous vous
véhiculez il ya eu deux temps dans ce
mandat de d'emmanuel macron il ya eu
l'époque castaner on sait qu'ils étaient
assez compliqué pour vous les policiers
est ce que les choses se sont un petit
peu apaisées avec le nouveau ministre de
l'intérieur qui n'est plus si nouveau
d'ailleurs gérald darmanin
alors il est clair que monsieur darmanin
est venu avec d'abord une casquette de
ministre de décompter de l'action
publique et qu'il a donné un grand coup
de pouce d'un point de vue du budget de
la police nationale alors c'est vrai que
nous allons profiter cette année d'un
plan de relance avec des dispositions
intéressantes au niveau de l'immobilier
au niveau des caméras mobiles même si
c'est pas encore suffisant au niveau des
du remplacement des véhicules donc ça ce
sont des dispositions qui sont
intéressantes et qui vont très
rapidement se mesurer sur le terrain
maintenant il y à un autre volet
plusieurs volets d'ailleurs qui sont par
exemple la formation continue des agents
nous demandons à ce qu'il y ait un
nombre d'heures dédié pour les foncières
de police puisqu'il pour qu'ils puissent
s'entraîner dans tous les domaines
d'ailleurs que ce soit les gestes et
professionnel que ce soit en matière
judiciaire que ce soit en gestes ans
notamment en contact avec le public
puisque souvent nous a reproché d'avoir
une certaine défaillance même s'il ya eu
un audit qui a déclaré quand même plus
de 400 commissariat avec de l'accueil du
public avec des opinions plutôt
favorable et puis enfin il faudra à
tordre le cou un jour à cette espèce de
petite musique qui dit qu' il y a dix
ans entre la police et la population jeu
frappât les sondages le montrent plus de
70% des descendants des montres ont une
opinion favorable et la police secours à
91%
par contre on ne peut pas en dire on
peut pas dire la même chose par rapport
à la justice
je rappelle que moins d'un français sur
deux fait confiance en la justice
clairement dix mille policiers de plus
sur le terrain plus de bleu en audi mais
cros 1 d'ici à 2022 c'est l'une des
débuts de solutions pour vous c'est pas
un scoop puisque c'était une annonce qui
avait des fêtes dès l'arrivée au pouvoir
du président de la république il avait
annoncé la création et ça c'est
important de le dire la création de dix
mille postes en police et en gendarmerie
pour l'instant nous n'en sommes pas au
bout des dix mille notamment des 7500
sur le périmètre ' police nationale mais
attention nous nous disant mettre des
effectifs c'est important certes
puisqu'il faut rattraper la perte de
personnel de police
quel que soit d'ailleurs les corps qui a
été effectuée pendant la révision
générale des politiques publiques
par contre attention il faut également
repenser les missions du policier le
recentrer sur son coeur de métier
supprimer toutes les tâches indues qui
nous empoisonnent le quotidien
simplifier les procédures pénales pour
que nos collègues qui travaillent en
investigation et bien il puisse enfin
faire du travail réel dans kate est pas
faire de la paperasse qui les
empoisonnent au quotidien et puis on
pardonne et moi ça ni 16 go dont les
laitages comme ça vous ne pensez pas
exemple au contrôle
suu kyi sont liés aux restrictions
sanitaires on imagine que ça vous prend
beaucoup de temps ça alors ça nous prend
beaucoup de temps mais c'est vrai qu'on
préférait courir après les délinquants
maintenant il ya une crise sanitaire
qu'il faut absolument combattre et tous
les acteurs sont importants je crois que
il faut pas occulter le fait que malgré
tous les contrôles ont eu un effet même
si on n'est pas dans le tout répressif
et que mes collègues sur terrain où fo
ont fait preuve de beaucoup de
discernement quand je parle des tâches
ardues c'est par exemple les gars
préfecture s'est par exemple les
transfèrements de détenus alors que
normalement ça devrait être rebasculer à
la pénitentiaire
je pense notamment à tout ce qui a trait
aux procurations électorale et le
ministre de l'intérieur a annoncé qu'il
y aurait des dispositions qui serait
prise parce que nous arrivons dans un
calendrier électoral important avec les
régionales et départementales et les
présidentielles en 2022
donc ça ça fait partie des choses qu'il
faut remettre au quotidien tout comme
d'ailleurs la loi sécurité globale et on
espère que le transfert notamment des
ivresses publiques et manifestes à la
police municipale se fera intégralement
la ramèneront qui fait aussi de la lutte
contre les trafics de drogue
une priorité c'est la mère des batailles
ans dit il vous partagez le même constat
alors bien sûr parce que nous ça fait
des années qu'on dit le trafic des
stupéfiants
il génère d'abord beaucoup d'argent plus
pratiquement 2 3 milliards d'euros
il génère une économie parallèle il crée
en fait de la délinquance au quotidien
et on voit bien dans les réactions dans
certains quartiers que la police elle
gêne et que du coup on tente d'attaquer
la police parce que il faut pas qu'elle
fasse son travail sereinement
oui c'est un combat de tous les instants
mais attention on ne nous trompons pas
il faut à la fois s'attaquer au point
dit il mais surtout s'attaquer aux
réseaux aux grands réseaux de trafic de
stupéfiants et il faut aussi que
derrière
la justice elle fasse son travail et
lorsque nous amenons des procédures qui
sont parfois très compliqué très longue
dans le temps eh bien il faut aussi que
derrière il est une réponse pénale qui
soit adaptée extrêmement ferme pour pas
qu'on se retrouve avec les mêmes
personnes qui commettent les mêmes
méfaits
quand ils reviennent notamment dans leur
quartier les mesures d'éloignement en
tout leur sens d'ailleurs ça sera ma
dernière question à ce qu'aujourd'hui
clairement la police ait les moyens de
démanteler ces trafics parce que vous
nous dites voilà on sent qu'on gêne on
est souvent attaqué sur le terrain le
jour où la guerre sera lancée vraiment à
ces trafics de drogue est ce que il n'ya
pas une crainte d'un embrasement des
quartiers difficiles mais l'embrasement
il est panier ça mon trafic de
stupéfiants il est lié surtout à
l'impunité
aujourd'hui n'ont plus peur d'attaqués
de tendre des guet-apens aux policiers
qui arrivent sur le terrain même quand
d'ailleurs ils font des patrouilles tout
ça mais qui sont pas dans un acte de
répression et d'ailleurs pour aller plus
loin il attaque même les banquiers
lorsqu'ils portent secours aux personnes
donc vous voyez à quel point on en est
arrivé à une banalisation de l'ultra
violence
et puis surtout un rejet de l'autorité
des tas de tout ce qui porte un uniforme
et je crois que là aussi il faudra qu'il
y ait un travail vous avez demain on va
manifester devant les tribunaux
judiciaires parce que nous pensons que
le verdict de
suite au procès de viry-châtillon bas
est un exemple et nous dénonçons depuis
des années la justice ne rend pas la
justice à la hauteur des préjudices
subis à la hauteur je dirais des
infractions commises c'est bien pour ça
que nous demandons dans le cadre du bobo
de la sécurité la création d'un
observatoire de la réponse pénale pour
qu'on fasse de la transparence sur les
infractions commises les peines
encourues les peines prononcées surtout
des peines exécutées
parce qu'aujourd'hui en france on parle
pas beaucoup on fait beaucoup de gestion
police de population carcérale mais on
ne parle pas beaucoup
je dirais des individus qui sont
interpellés et la manière donc dont ils
réparent les dommages qu'ils ont causés
à la société merci beaucoup de tristesse
godon d'avoir été avec nous et je le
disais donc 1 en ouverture de cette
interview
emmanuel macron qui était à montpellier
un seul arni et qui a défendu son bilan
sur la sécurité après avoir répondu à
nos confrères du figaro quand un mot
clair trois ans après le début de son
mandat
emmanuel macron fait le point sur sa
politique sécuritaire
lors d'un entretien accordé au quotidien
le figaro le chef de l'état dit se
battre pour le droit à la vie paisible
avant d'évoquer des promesses faites
pendant sa campagne
parmi elles l'objectif de créer dix
mille postes de policiers et gendarmes
supplémentaires d'ici la fin de son
quinquennat
on tiendra le calendrier et il est
normal qu'on parvienne à l'objectif
progressivement puisqu'il faut le temps
de former les policiers recrutés ils
seront tous sur le terrain avant la fin
du quinquennat
aujourd'hui 4508 policiers et 1706
gendarmes ont déjà été recrutés soit
6214 membres des forces de l'ordre
nous aurons en complément des sept
années 2000 policiers et gendarmes de
plus et parmi ces nouveaux policiers
l'essentiel iront directement en
sécurité publique c'est à dire sur la
voie publique
parmi ces renforts qui devraient arriver
lors des prochains mois on décompte 135
nouveaux postes à lyon 100 à marseille
ou encore 117 à lille outre ces renforts
sur le terrain
emmanuel macron a dévoilé qu'une réserve
nationale de 30000 hommes sera créé dans
la police celle de la gendarmerie
passera quant à elle de 38 à 50 me
l'homme selon le président français
emmanuel macron souhaite rassurer les
français en mettant plus
forces de l'ordre dans les rues des mots
qui ne passe pas dans l'opposition
certains membres de la droite notamment
de la droite nationaliste n'ont pas
hésité à critiquer les déclarations du
président français
cet hymne des revues de macron ne
rassemble que des slogans électoraux à
un an de la présidentielle alors que
depuis quatre ans les actes défaillant
conduit à l'explosion de la délinquance
à des niveaux d'immigration record et à
une montée inédite de l'islamisme le
président du chaos de la violence
partout tout le temps de la division de
l'injustice sociale fiscale territoriale
nous vend aujourd'hui la vie paisible
rien ne nous sera épargné
quand vous êtes président de la
république vous n'annoncez pas vous fait
il est président depuis 2017
les effectifs de police et de
gendarmerie ils sont dix mille policiers
ce n'est rien j'en ai demandé trente
mille il faut un référendum sur une
procédure pénale renouvelé et pas de
bracelet électronique
mais des peines appliquées en prison il
n'y a pas un pays au monde plus laxiste
avec les délinquants
dans son entretien au figaro emmanuel
macron a révélé qu'il souhaitait lancer
un grand débat national sur la
consommation de drogue et ses effets le
président français a également réaffirmé
qu'il tiendrait sa promesse de créer
quinze mille places supplémentaires dans
les prisons d'ici 2027
si 7000 d'entre elles ont été lancées en
2018 il n'est pas certain qu'elles
seront prêtes comme promis en 2022
le quotidien le monde révélait en
juillet 2019 qu'en raison d'une baisse
du budget de la justice
la création des structures
d'accompagnement à la sortie allait être
repoussé
il en va de même pour deux prisons
expérimental qui selon le quotidien
devrait attendre à minima 2023 pour voir
le jour et un an de l'élection
présidentielle quel bilan dresser de
l'action du président sur le volet
sécuritaire emmanuel macron at il échoué
sur la sécurité où il est trop tôt de le
dire c'est l'objet de notre face à face
ce soir
[Musique]
avec nous pour en parler raphaël gauvin
débuté la république en marge 5e
circonscription de saône-et-loire
bonsoir raphaël gauvin merci d'être avec
nous à vos côtés pour débattre belle et
les boyer sénatrice les républicains des
bouches du rhône
bonsoir valérie boyer merci d'être avec
nous en direct sur rt france annonce
donc de renfort à aujourd'hui encore
message de soutien aux forces de l'ordre
qui en ont bien besoin au 4e mandat
quel est le bilan du président les
violences et les actes de 5,8
d'insécurité sont-ils moindre ombre dans
le pays raphaël gauvin moi j'entraîne à
risque où il ya une autre question alors
je la répète avec plaisir annonce de
renforts on a vu un coup de
communication diront certains du
président de la république aujourd'hui
clairement y at il un mieux sur le front
de l'insécurité en france aujourd'hui
après quatre ans de mandat emmanuel
macron je pense que le client la
sécurité en face et de le débat de ce
soir là la sécurité elle était au coeur
du programme présidentiel et elle est au
coeur depuis 2007 de nos de notre action
vrai voulu rappeler dans votre dans
votre reportage c'est dix mille
policiers et gendarmes supplémentaires
on a fait à peu près la moitié là il ya
des annonces supplémentaires
l'opposition dénoncé que c'était juste
des effets de com mais c'est c'est de
l'action c'est des choses très concrètes
je vois moi par exemple amazon c'est
dans les annonces du président c'est
demain c'est ce policier de plus qui
vont arriver c'est des policiers en plus
c'est des moyens aussi en plus le budget
sur en matière de sécurité que ce soit
intérieure ou justice augmenté de de
plus d'un milliard depuis 2010 est le
budget de la justice qu'on a voté
l'année dernière c'est plus lui % 8 %
qui va être pour l'essentiel consacré à
rénover rénover les tribunaux rénover
les prisons qui est plus de deux places
supplémentaires
et puis le bilan de notre action c'est
aussi une adaptation constante de nos
moyens juridiques
pour rendre notre législation beaucoup
plus opérationnels pour lutter contre la
délinquance
vous pouvez rire mes chers collègues
mais c'est la loi site que l'on va
revoir dans quelques mois c'est la loi
contre la sécurité globale qui renforce
qui donne plus de moyens juridiques aux
policiers municipaux sais c'est
l'ensemble de ces mesures qu'il faut que
bien sûr les choses sont pas parfaites
bien sûr que j'entends les yaka fokon il
est toujours plus qui propose des
référendum ou des mesures qui ils le
savent eux mêmes ne sont absolument pas
opérationnel et a été quant à eux
étaient aux affaires ont baissé les
montants qui était dédiée à la justice
le rappel sous nicolas sarkozy pour
peugeot mais voilà et ans lors du débat
si nicolas sarkozy ces dix mille
policiers en moins sous le quinquennat
de nicolas sarkozy sous le quinquennat
de d'emmanuel macron ce sera dix mille
policiers supplémentaires les voyez
votre réputation c'est vrai que cette
critique elle revient elle revient
souvent sur le sur le mandat sarkozy le
nombre de policiers qui ont baissé oui
je rappelle que le niveau de sécurité
sous nicolas sarkozy et le niveau d
agression ce que nicolas sarkozy a
baissé de façon très significative alors
qu'il avait augmenté dans le mandat dieu
n'existe pas et que depuis trois ans que
manuel mc ren est en place les boues
citer un chiffre pour par harvey de
chiffres les téléspectateurs mais il
faut savoir que les violences aux
dépositaires des forces de l'ordre c'est
une centaine par jour soit + 21 % et moi
je me réjouis de voir que emmanuel
macron va mettre en place des policiers
c'est moins de 1% du plan de relance qui
est consacrée à la mise en place de
policiers pour l'instant on est loin du
compte et
loin du compte des promesses et si on
fait le parallèle avec ce qui se passe
pour les places de prison je rappelle
que le pays andin république avait
promis pendant un petit problème un
petit problème voilà de réseau avec
valérie boyer malheureusement raphaël
gauvin l'image qu'on retiendra quand
même cet après midi c'est celle
d'emmanuel micron qui a embarqué avec
une équipe de la bac 1 pour faire le
tour des points de vente de drogue dans
la ville de montpellier au même moment
il ya eu un échange de balles dans la
ville un homme est entre la vie et la
mort ce soir à ce que ce n'est pas là
les cruels illustration de ce qui se
passe communication d'un côté et
principe de réalité du terrain de
l'autre il ya et notamment depuis le thé
confinement et on le voit au niveau
local r moi j'ai des cheveux ou 6e sur
ma circonscription il ya une
augmentation extrêmement fort des
violences physiques notamment des
violences contre les personnes
dépositaires de l'autorité
c'est un phénomène qui n'est pas limitée
juste à la france alors les causes sans
doute une banalisation de la violence
notamment avec les les réseaux sociaux
c'est quelque chose sur lequel il faut
qu'on agisse et c'est pour ça que les
annonces qui ont été faites d'un
renforcement pour qu'ils aient plus de
policiers sur le terrain
et puis surtout c'est pour ça que on a
mis en place des dispositions pour
renforcer les les les peines et
notamment les peines encourues contre
les auteurs de violences contre les
forces de l'ordre sorte heureusement
récupérer alors j'ai pas entendu tout le
débat mais je voudrais terminer sur ce
que je disais tout à l'heure c'est
compliqué quand même de croire emmanuel
macron parce que
déjà c'est lui qui a dit sur un réseau
social qui a parlé de violences
policières donc c'est quand même un
message qui d'une grande violence et
d'une grande défiance vis-à-vis des
forces de l'ordre est ce que je voudrais
dire c'est que il peut pas y avoir et là
je pense que nous sommes tous d'accord
de sécurité si le continuum police
justice n'est pas respectée or
aujourd'hui on a les plus grandes
difficultés avec les constructions de
peines de prison ce sont des difficultés
pour la dignité des personnes
incarcérées mais aussi des difficultés
pour la sécurité des français
et quand dans la campagne présidentielle
emmanuel macron avait promis seize mille
places
ensuite il a revu ses prétentions à la
blesse 7500 places en 2018 que 4500
places en 2019
aujourd'hui on en a que 1500 en plus
donc on voit bien que si on peut pas
demander aux policiers et s'ils sont
plus tant mieux compte tenu de
l'augmentation de la sécurité de faire
leur boulot si c'est pour relâcher ou ne
pas incarcérer les personnes qui sont
condamnées
je rappelle qu aujourd'hui 45% des
personnes condamnées à de la prison ne
le sont pas ne sont pas en prison six
mois après leur condamnation dont ont
toutes ces difficultés sont majeurs on
les a souligné on a fait des
propositions très importantes et je
voudrais illustrer mon propos par la
sinistre histoire qui est arrivée à
l'âge analystes 17 ans qui a été violée
par quelqu'un qui devait être en prison
et qui n'a pas effectué la totalité de
sa peine
donc aujourd'hui et les parents ont
porté plainte contre l'état et je les
comprends et je les soutiens dans cette
démarche parce que on ne peut plus
accepter ça la justice est rendue au nom
du peuple français
et ces personnes qui sont dangereuses
pour la société je rappelle quand même
que son agresseur avait avait agressé
son conjoint qui avait lu saint geours
de dit était ce un jour d'itt et et je
préfère même pas pensé l'état dans
lequel cette pauvre dame pouvait se
trouver
donc aujourd'hui on voit bien que ce
continuum est rompu et qu'il ya un
problème de confiance dans l'application
des peines et moi j'entends tout ce que
le
ministre de la justice dit mais j'ai
participé au texte sur le séparatisme
comme celui sur la sécurité globale et
je note que nombre de propositions que
nous avons faites n'ont pas été entendus
par le gouvernement
alors moi je me réjouis du fait que nous
ayons plusieurs des policiers
supplémentaires même si j'attends
vraiment de voir si cette promesse sera
tenue
ce que je constate de façon tout à fait
concrète c'est que sur l'équipement des
policiers qui est quand même majeur
parce que nous avons par exemple
beaucoup plus de policiers par habitant
qu'en grande bretagne mais leur
équipement en france est quand même
défaillant et bien que là le budget a
baissé donc il faut de la cohérence à la
fois sur l'équipement des policiers sur
leur affectation
aujourd'hui on a des policiers qui sont
là pour vérifier si on a bien rempli nos
attestation qu'ovide et si on respecte
le confinement fin de pardonnez moi
parce que c'est une fois laissez lui le
temps de la parole aussi a fait le
mauvais justement est-ce que voilà
l'uniforme on va changer apparemment
d'uniformes ce que c'était bien le
l'urgence aujourd'hui dans ce débat sur
sur l'insécurité en france c'est vrai
que ses critiques sur le laxisme de la
justice ça revient extrêmement souvent
ce que c'est pas là qu'il faut agir en
priorité essayer de faire peut-être tous
les deux s'il vous plaît des réponses
courtes de longue haleine de très longue
haleine et il faut évidemment renforcer
les moyens les moyens de la police mais
également les moyens de justifier et ça
passe à un nombre grandissant de
construction de places de prison
on l'a voté je me rappelle plus lui %
dans le budget les liens dans le budget
de cette année qui seront consacrés pour
l'essentiel à la construction de
nouvelles
j'aimerais jouer mais on est très loin
de la construction dépasse de plus 10
ans et aujourd'hui c'est un problème de
dignité pour les personnes incarcérées
mais c'est aussi un problème de sécurité
pour les français comment pouvez-vous
aujourd'hui dire aux français que les
personnes n'existent les peines ne sont
pas exécutés parce qu'il n'ya pas de
places de prison d'une part ou que
certaines certaines personnes n'ont pas
fait leur peine dans leur totalité ou
même dans la moitié de la totalité
compte tenu des réductions peine parce
que head risquer d'attraper le coc vide
et qu'elles ont commis des crimes et des
délits par des personnes sur des
personnes sondées française alors
qu'elle devait être en sécurité alors
que ces personnes devaient être hors
d'état de nuire
donc moi je jeu j'espère vraiment que
ces policiers supplémentaires vont
arriver mais jusqu'à présent je constate
qu'on a eu des annonces qu'on est à un
an pile de des présidentielles et que
j'ai plutôt l'impression de voir un
président de la république en campagne
avec un bilan sur le plan de la sécurité
qui est quand même très très mauvais
compte tenu de l'augmentation des
atteintes aux personnes compte tenu des
manifestations qui ont eu lieu tout au
long du mandat de d'emmanuel macro et
compte tenu aussi du fait que les
agressions aux détenteurs de l'autorité
publique n'ont cessé d'augmenter
les policiers ont été victimes de
violence et c'est le président de la
république lui même qui parle de
violences policières ça c'est
inadmissible mais je peux vous assurer
de demain je participerai aux
manifestations devant la préfecture de
police pour m'insurger face aux peines
qui ont été prononcées vis-à-vis des
policiers qui ont été attaqués en
banlieue parisienne et brûlé est ce que
vous pouvez me laisser parler pas
répondre je peux vous dire est
reproduite sur les chiffres c'est
totalement faux
encore une fois on a noté une
augmentation on est dirigée va permettre
la construction de plusieurs prisons ce
que vous dites sur les nerfs si vous
êtes sur le terrain moi j'étais la
semaine dernière à l'agenda ou shana et
je peux vous dire que l'augmentation des
crédits qui a permis l'arrivée des
nouveaux véhicules
c'est quelque chose c'est quelque chose
qui arrive car était au chrtr donc ce
que vous dites sur la baisse de
l'augmentation de la dotation pour les
équipes d'épée les équipements c'est un
mensonge c'est pas vrai il ya une
réalité sur
baisse des moyens moins 24% pour
l'acquisition des véhicules - 27 consent
pour l'acquisition des munitions détail
des déceptions de places de prison nous
sommes très loin des 16 mille places
promises
merci en tout cas à tous les deux repas
reçoit dans une bataille de chiffres
c'est vrai que c'est compliqué à
vérifier en tout cas on n'aura pas la
réponse ce soir mais on va s'empresser
d'aller vérifier ces chiffres objectifs
merci en tout cas à tous les deux
d'avoir accepté ce face à face est
pardonné mots pour ses petits problèmes
de son et de micros et de réseaux voilà
merci rafale gauvin et valérie boyer
d'avoir été avec nous restez avec nous
dans quelques instants nous parlerons du
pakistan les onze policiers pris en
otage hier ont été libérés ton ce matin
le quai d'orsay a rappelé quinze de ses
diplomates et demande à ses
ressortissants de quitter le pays
et puis direction les états-unis ou
procès chauvine touche à sa fin
aujourd'hui débute le réquisitoire de
l'accusation et la plaidoirie de la
défense explique accusé d'avoir tué de
georges fleury refuse toujours de
témoigner
[Musique]
la crise du côté de 19 à semble-t-il
mise en lumière lippert mondialisation
et les contraintes qui vont avec
démondialiser pas sur un coup de
baguette magique ça coûte cher de
relocaliser il faut aussi changer ce
pourquoi les entreprises sont partis il
ya de grandes façon de le voir et qui
implique des stratégies qui sont
complètement différentes
vous pouvez essayer de refaire venir de
la vieille industrie qui a disparu ou
des secteurs qui ont disparu mais s'ils
ont disparu il ya une vue il ya une
bonne raison
l'autre façon de voir c'est de savoir
quels sont les nouveaux secteurs
auxquels sont les secteurs l'avenir
qu'on peut arriver à conserver chez nous
si un jour on veut re localiser et bien
il faut déjà empêché les cerveaux de
partir ou en tous cas lors donner des
moyens pour qu'ils aient envie de rester
[Musique]
20h30 sous et les bienvenus en direct
sur rt france si vous nous rejoignez en
russie alexeï navalni va être transféré
vers un hôpital pour prisonniers
son état de santé je cite satisfaisant
selon les autorités carcérales est en
grève de la faim depuis trois semaines
bruxelles demande un accès immédiat à
des médecins de confiance des précisions
de notre correspondant à moscou vera
goffman l'état de santé des individus
condamnés et emprisonnés en russie ne
devrait pas susciter l'intérêt des
représentants des autres pays a estimé
le porte-parole du président russe
dmitri peskov a également souligné que
le kremlin n'avait aucune réaction aux
récentes déclarations de représentants
occidentaux hausse
à ce sujet il a également rappelé que
les appels à manifester en soutien dans
l'excès navalni sont lancés du pied
l'étranger je vous propose d'écouter en
outre nous n'avons aucune réaction à ce
type de déclarations faites par les
représentants d'autres états
l'état de santé des individus condamnés
et emprisonnés en russie ne peut et ne
doit pas faire l'objet de leurs intérêts
dans le cas où des manifestations non
autorisées seraient initiés
elle serait automatiquement qualifié
d'illégitime et des forces de police et
la justice rendront vis-à-vis d'elle les
mesures prévues par la loi de la
fédération de russie
il est très important de rappeler qu'une
fois encore ses appels à caractère
provocateur ne sont même pas lancé dans
le sol russe ils sont lancés par des
individus séjournant à l'étranger il
serait probablement son c'est de
toujours garder cela en mémoire
l'état de santé de l'ex et navale n'est
a été jugé satisfaisant par le service
pénitentiaire russe après examen par un
médecin
l'opposant russes purge actuellement une
peine de deux ans et demi de prison la
justice russe a évoqué en février
dernier
le sursis dans une condamnation
remontant en 2014
il s'agit d'une affaire de détournement
de fonds dans la filiale russe du groupe
français yves rocher et on en vient à
présent aux tensions entre l'ukraine et
la russie à l'issue d'une
visioconférence avec les ministres des
affaires étrangères de lieux le chef de
la diplomatie européenne joseph morel a
évoqué un risque d'escaladé avec le
déploiement selon lui 250 mille
militaires russes à la frontière avec
l'ukraine
les occidentaux qui dénoncent la
présence de forces armées de plus en
plus importante à la frontière
ukrainienne
la russie de son côté rappelle qu'il
s'agit d'exercices militaires et avec le
conflit débuter en 2014 l'est de
l'ukraine se trouve isolé du reste du
pays ainsi les infrastructures sont à
l'arrêt c'est le cas du stade de
football de donetsk privé de compétition
depuis près de sept ans antoine perraud
notre reporter sur place nous raconte
l'histoire du dombass arena qui aura été
tour à tour témoins et acteurs de ce
conflit
bienvenue à la dombass arena le stade de
la ville de donetsk allons voir
l'intérieur
ce stade de plus de 52000 places a été
construit pour accueillir les matches du
chap tu redonnes y est devenu dans les
années 2000
l'une des meilleures équipe d'ukraine
mais aussi d'europe le shakhtar de niet
n'est pas seulement l'un des leaders du
football ukrainien c'est aussi un club
réputé au niveau européen
il a remporté la coupe d'ukraine à plus
de 100 entreprises a été sept fois
champion d'ukraine et a gagné à trois
reprises la super contact mais son plus
grand succès à ce jour et la victoire en
coupe de l'uefa que l'équipe a remporté
en 2009 certains matches de l'euro 2012
ont également été jouée ici
l'équipe de france ainsi joué deux
matchs sur cette pelouse deux matches
dont un contre l'angleterre et un autre
contre le pays hôte l'ukraine à partir
de 2009 le chakhtior a donc élu domicile
dans cette enceinte mais hélas pas pour
très longtemps
le dernier match à la donbass arena a eu
lieu le 2 mai 2014 recevait leach au
viet c'est le shakhtar qui a gagné 3
pendant les heures les plus sombres du
conflit le président du club a organisé
des distributions d'aidé alimentaire
dans l'enceinte même du stade afin de
venir en aide aux plus démunis dont
l'impossibilité de jouer à cause des
combats
le club a déménagé à lviv dans l'ouest
de l'ukraine puis kharkov et enfin à
kiev
résultat plus personne ne joue sur cette
pelouse qui malgré tout continuent
d'être entretenu en ce moment malgré les
actions militaires et la situation dans
notre région
la direction fait toutes les démarches
nécessaires pour préserver cet objet
unique avec le soutien du gouvernement
de la république du ministère de la
jeunesse et des sports
nous essayons également de conserver
tout le personnel qui travaillait au
stade dans la période d'avant guerre des
spécialistes hautement qualifiés
capables d'entretenir cette
infrastructure
[Musique]
l'espoir des habitants de john yates qui
est plus particulièrement des amoureux
du ballon rond est maintenant de voir
leur équipe revenir jouer dans leur
stade est direction présents le pakistan
ou plusieurs figures religieuses ont
appelé à une grève nationale aujourd'hui
en soutien à un parti islamiste radical
qui organisent des manifestations contre
le droit de caricaturer en france le tlp
c'est son nom qui est libéré ce matin
onze policiers pris en otage hier ses
partisans demandent la libération de
leurs chefs et des militants arrêtés la
semaine dernière ils demandent aux
autorités d'annuler leur décision
d'interdire l'organisation paris a
rappelé quinze diplomates et demande à
ses ressortissants de quitter le pays
temporairement le premier ministre
appelle les militants anti france à
revenir au calme les détails avec mehdi
et ski fis les commerces affichent
portes closes ce matin dans les rues de
karachi
à l'instar de plusieurs transports
publics ils suivent un mouvement de
grève nationale à l'appel de leaders
religieux pour protester contre
l'attitude du gouvernement à l'égard du
tnp ce parti islamiste radicale très
influent dans le pays a pris en otage
aux policiers ce dimanche avant de
libérer ce lundi matin à l'issue de
négociations avec les autorités
une démonstration de force qui s'inscrit
dans le mouvement mené depuis une
semaine afin d'obtenir la rupture de
toutes relations diplomatiques avec la
france
l'hexagone cible des protestations en
raison des propos tenus par emmanuel
macron en octobre dernier le président
français avait notamment défendu le
droit du journal satirique charlie hebdo
de publier des caricatures du prophète
de l'islam une position considérée comme
une provocation par une partie de la
population du pakistan
de leur côté les autorités pakistanaises
ont décidé de classer le parti en
question comme groupe terroriste à cause
de leur mode d'action violent ce samedi
le premier ministre a tenté de clarifier
la situation
en condamnant justement ces méthodes
laissez-moi préciser ceci à l'attention
de tous ici et à l'étranger
notre gouvernement est intervenu contre
le tlp en vertu des lois antiterroristes
quand ils ont contesté l'autorité de
l'état ont fait usage de la violence et
ont attaqué la population et les forces
de l'ordre depuis la semaine dernière le
tlp a été officiellement interdit et
plusieurs de ses membres auraient été
tués d'après plusieurs chefs du
mouvement ce dimanche une journée de
protestation particulièrement violente
lors de laquelle des affrontements ont
eu lieu entre protestataires et forces
de sécurité la police a tout de suite
commencé à pilonner et a tiré des balles
directement sur nous nos garçons ont été
blessés certains ont reçu des balles
dans la poitrine
d'autres ont reçu des balles dans la
tête nous ne sommes pas armés
ils ont martyrisé des dizaines de nos
hommes nous sommes désarmés nous n'avons
que l'amour du prophète
rien d'autre nous voulons qu'ils nous
tirent dessus ou qu'ils expulsent
l'ambassadeur français parce que rien
n'est plus important pour nous que
l'honneur du prophète
malgré leur interdiction les violences
les membres du tnp entendent bien
poursuivre leur mobilisation contre la
france une manifestation d'ampleur à
l'appel du parti est prévue ce mardi
pour faire à nouveau pression sur le
gouvernement pakistanais et pour en
parler nous sommes avec nos deux
branches maison expert en relations
internationales bonsoir plonge saison
merci d'être avec nous en direct sur
arte france les ressortissants français
ont-ils vraiment intérêt à quitter
provisoirement le pakistan comme le
recommande l'ambassade française à
islamabad
il va en tout cas être très prudent de
mal puisque le mouvement qui regroupe
fakih a été interdite par le
gouvernement pakistanais a lancé un
nouveau mot d'ordre de manifestation
demain essentiellement à islamabad et
par conséquent il faut que les
ressortissants français soient très
prudent alors c'est vrai que les
autorités françaises leur ont demandé de
quitter le pakistan
temporairement
ils sont pas très nombreux ils sont
environ 450 inscrits dans nos deux
consulats et la plupart d'entre eux
travaillent dans les grandes entreprises
qui sont d'ailleurs dans l'activité
n'est absolument pas remise en cause et
ses grandes entreprises sont des
employeurs de nombreux pakistanais
certains donc sont déjà partis d'autres
vents gouvernement partir en ce qui
concerne nos compatriotes et je pense
qu'ils doivent rester très prudent tout
état de cause mais je pense que
évidemment c'est un peu un dilemme
puisque certains d'entre eux ne veulent
pas quitter leur travail qu' ils sont
très attachés à leur entreprise et que
d'ailleurs la présence française et est
assez faire au pakistan comparé à la
présence économique d'autres pays
occidentaux
alors où en sont les relations
diplomatiques entre la france et le
pakistan
alors il n'y a pas d'ambassadeur du
pakistan à à paris pour une raison de
circonstances le l'ancien ambassadeur
avait fini son mandat au mois d'août
dernier
ils ont parti et imran khan le premier
ministre pakistanais a négligé de nommer
tout de suite un nouvel ambassadeur
ensuite lorsque l' affaire a commencé
avec l affaire des caricatures et bien
lehmann cannes à penser que pour apaiser
les choses il valait mieux différer la
nomination d'un ambassadeur pakistanais
à paris donc l'ambassade fonctionne sous
la direction d'un chargé d'affaires
pour ce qui est de notre ambassade à
islamabad
eh bien le gouvernement français a
retiré 15 membres pour des raisons de
sécurité mais les chefs de service
continu des plats l'ambassadeur aussi et
là encore ça fonctionne et sous la
direction de l'ambassadeur naturellement
en prenant les mesures de sécurité qui
s'imposent sécurité qui en fonction de
conventions de genève est assurée par le
gouvernement pakistanais à l'extérieur
de l'ambassade et bien entendu par des
gendarmes à l'intérieur de l'ambassade
pour le reste on a bien vu que le
mouvement islamiste radical qui est
interdite depuis le
16 novembre concentre concentre son
action sur l'expulsion de l'ambassadeur
de france
c'est sa demande principale il veut la
rupture des relations diplomatiques et
l'expulsion de lance de l'ambassadeur de
france parce que il n'a pas accepté que
charles ix est de re publie les
caricatures au début du mois de
septembre les caricatures du prophète au
moment du delà de le penser des
attentats des attentats de charlie hebdo
précisément et il a encore moins
acceptée naturellement que le président
de la république française disent que
les caricatures était quelque chose qui
n'était pas question d'interdire en
france qui avait une tradition française
républicaine et que par conséquent il ne
il interdirait pas la publication de
tels de telles caricatures donc depuis
et bien ce mouvement extrémiste
encore une fois interdit maintenant par
le gouvernement par le gouvernement
pakistanais
demande le départ de l'ambassadeur de
france alors on verra comment se déroule
la manifestation de demain
mais effectivement il faut être très
attentif
la situation peut-être taux peut tourner
très rapidement à des violences qui
auraient eu il ya beaucoup à lahore et
il ya eu des morts des deux côtés
du côté de la police nous aussi du côté
des manifestants
les manifestants en tuant des policiers
et en retenant en otage
onze d'entre eux pendant presque une
journée entière se sont mis hors la loi
par conséquent ils ont en principe
perdit l'appui du gouvernement de vous
des de certains membres du gouvernement
pakistanais
si certains le soutenait et probablement
aussi des militaires dont on sait qu'ils
jouent un rôle clé au pakistan pour bien
qu'on comprenne creusement de sa maison
et y at-il une spécificité de ce pays
concernant l'apparition de mouvements
susceptibles de recourir à la violence
on peut prendre quelques exemples on
sait que le pakistan a toujours été très
lié avec ce qui se passait en un pénis
tant est que bien souvent il a servi de
refuge aux talibans
certains venant d'ailleurs s'entraîner
s'entraîner au pakistan deuxième exemple
les attentats de bombay qui ont fait
plus de 160 morts
avec d'ailleurs beaucoup d'étrangers de
touristes tuées dans ces attentats
et bien c'est un groupe qui venaient du
pakistan qui est venu par la mère qui
s'était entraîné au pakistan alors ça
n'était pas du tout le gouvernement ait
entraîné une enfin il avait trouvé
refuge au pakistan et les moyens pour
s'entraîner et à chaque fois qu'il ya un
attentat en un que ce soit contre le
parlement
que ce soit contre des militaires ou des
paramilitaires et bien effectivement les
groupes terroristes viennent du pakistan
c'est à dire qu'ils y ont un refuge une
sorte de sanctuaire et par conséquent
ceux ci donnent une image un petit peu
particulière alors aujourd'hui
l affaire des caricatures de charlie
hebdo a provoqué aussi des réactions
dans d'autres pays musulmans mais elles
se sont calmées elles se sentent apaisés
au pakistan non parce que en effet un
certain nombre d'extrémistes
il voit là le moyen probablement d'avoir
une de faire de croire aucune agitation
politique comme je le disais tout à
l'heure l'armée joue un rôle clé au
pakistan et notamment les services de
renseignement et fameux easy et il est
probable que l'isi est en train de
prendre parti sur cette affaire et que
probablement il a les moyens d'éviter de
nouveaux développements violent venant
de la part de ce groupe extrémiste
merci beaucoup au club blanchemaison
expert en relations internationales
aux etats unis à présent le procès de
derek chauvine touche à sa fin
aujourd'hui débute le réquisitoire de
l'accusation et la plaidoirie de la
défense
georges de floride a supplié jusqu'à ce
qu'il ne puisse plus parler ce sont les
mots glaçons le procureur face au jury
écouter naïma 9 minutes et 29 secondes
charge floyd est entouré d'un connu pas
un seul visage familier auquel dire ses
derniers mots mais il les a dit à
quelqu'un il les a dit à quelqu'un dont
il ne connaissait pas le nom mais il le
connaissait à cause de l'uniforme et de
l'insigne qu'il portait et il l'appelait
monsieur l'agent c'est comme ça qu'il
l'appelait monsieur l'agent monsieur
l'agent qui pouvait l'aider si nous
appelons la police lorsque nous avons
besoin des aides et il a supplié
monsieur l'agent les derniers mots de
georges floyd le 25 mai 2020 furent s'il
vous plaît je ne peux pas respirer et il
a dit ces mots à l'accusé
et retour sur ces trois semaines de
procès l'ex policier accusé d'avoir tué
djordje floyd refuse toujours de
témoigner quand un mot clair une
troisième semaine de procès sous le
signe de l'émotion philo nice floyd
était appelé à témoigner lundi lors du
procès de derek chauvine le frère de
george clooney n'a pas pu cacher ses
larmes face aux questions qui lui
étaient posées
mais je me suis marié le 24 mai je me
suis mariée et mon frère a été tué le 25
mai et ma mère est morte le 30 mai c'est
un mois tout amer alors que je suis
censé être heureux qu'en ce mois arrive
quelques jours auparavant
la défense avait avancé la thèse selon
laquelle georges floyd était décédée à
la suite d'une overdose d'opiacés
hypothèse rejetée par un cardiologue à
la barre lundi dernier dans cette
affaire monsieur georges d'orques floyd
est mort d'un arrêt cardio respiratoire
qui a été causé par un faible taux
d'oxygène et ce faible niveau d'oxygène
a été entraînée par la position face
contre terre contraintes et l'asphyxié
positionnelle auquel il a été soumis
le fait marquant de cette troisième
semaine de procès intervient jeudi
appelé à la barre des règles chauvine a
invoqué le cinquième amendement à la
constitution américaine qui lui donne le
droit de garder le silence lors de son
procès avez vous pris la décision
aujourd'hui de témoigner ou d'invoquer
vos droits liés au cinquième amendement
j'invoque aujourd'hui mes droits liés au
cinquième amendement en parallèle du
procès les tensions se sont ravivées ces
derniers jours
en cause la mort de john terry est
qu'une policière à tuer explique ensuite
avoir confondu son taser avec son arme
de service le 11 avril dernier dans une
banlieue de minneapolis ville où
vivaient ou est morte georges floyd
des manifestations tournant parfois les
émeutes ont éclaté tout au long de la
semaine dernière la police a arrêté des
dizaines de manifestants et un
couvre-feu à 22h hammam été décrétée
pour calmer les esprits et pour en
parler nous sommes en direct depuis new
york avec chan reek mot aux journalistes
politiques c'est notre rubrique vu de
l'extérieur ce soir bonsoir
schalwyk mot merci d'être avec nous en
direct sur rt france trois semaines
d'audience mais derek chauvine à
l'accusé reste silencieux définitivement
son silence peut-il le desservir ou au
contraire ça peut être une stratégie
payante
il est possible que les accusés ne
viennent pas à la barre lors de ses
procès le poma je n'y accorde pas trop
d'importance
la défense un cas très solide
c'est le procès de l'année
cette affaire a tout changé l'année
dernière on permettait en première page
de tous les journaux l'est toujours
aujourd'hui
et pourtant on n'entend pas beaucoup
parler de ce qui se passe dans la salle
d'audience heures dans les journaux dans
les organes de presse les plus libéraux
de gauche ce qui semble indiquer que mon
cas c'est parce que l'un pour derek roy
vivement des prix ce procès comme un
procès
très fort en émotions les experts de la
défense ont avancé des arguments
percutants et le procureur doivent
trouver beaucoup d'éléments ils doivent
prouver qu'il ya une intention de tuer
jacques flies il faut prouver que
derrière le cheval n'a pas agi la
fonction des protocoles policiers il
faut prouver que ces actions menées là
la mort de cet homme et qu'il ne s'est
pas agi quelques conjonction de drogue
de stress et d'autres problèmes
donc c'est compliqué nous allons croire
que le sel de la justice est aveugle de
dieu tu le fais il suffit qu'un jury cas
j'aurais dis ce que je t'aime jurés ne
sont pas complètement détachée du
contexte politique
regardez la réaction regardez une force
les coups droits qui veulent voir des
règles chauvin prison je ne sais pas si
beaucoup de jurés pourraient le courage
d'être la personne qui dit cet homme est
innocent témoin pour la défense ont vu
leurs maisons et vandalisé maxine waters
une députée du congrès américain a
demandé à ce qu'il y ait davantage de
manifestations que la situation soit
plus électrique
donc il ya beaucoup de pression sur ces
jurés et ils délibèrent en ce moment
chaque brique moi en tout cas vous de la
france c'est vrai qu'on a vu des images
assez insoutenable de cet homme
d'ailleurs je vous rappelle les mots du
procureur il a supplié jusqu'à ce qu'il
ne puisse plus parler on rappelle qu un
pneumologue a écarté la thèse de la
défense selon laquelle il serait mort
d'une arythmie cardiaque même le chef de
la police de minneapolis a déclaré que
son ancien agent avait violé les règles
qu'est ce qui vous permet aujourd'hui de
dire que la défense semble dans une
mauvaise posture
cela repose sur l'intention les
officiers ça avec tous leurs mouvements
sont enregistrés ils portent des caméras
autour de la foule a également deux
caméras
il ya des caméras dans la rue et sa
leçon ces caméras il faut se demander
y avait-il une attention de te paie lui
mais quand je floyd il officiait comme
s'est il agi et mal alors qu'ils
savaient que leur acte été enregistré si
ce n'était pas leur intention c'est
considérer qu'ils agissaient en fonction
des règles conformément à ce qu'ils ont
droit de faire alors
c'est une autre affaire et il ya des
experts qui ont parlé de cela tout comme
il ya deux experts qui ont parlé de la
cause du décès des experts ont également
débattu sur la saturation d'oxygène dans
son lieu sans qui est très élevé pour
une personne qui aurait été asphyxiés
lisez je ne peux pas respirer je ne peux
pas respirer avant même que l'officier
le touch2 experts a dit que la police
est formé pour comprendre que si
quelqu'un dit je ne peux pas respirer
alors cette personne peut respirer car
il est impossible de parler lorsqu'on ne
peut pas respirer
donc ces officiers d'après leur
formation penser qu'ils agissaient de
manière tout à fait légale
pardonnez moi de vous vous coupez parce
que effectivement ça peut être un point
de vue qui n'est pas forcément qui fait
pas forcément l'unanimité mais
effectivement c'est une opinion voilà
que qu'on peut entendre
il n'empêche qu'on pense l'opinion
publique aux etats-unis vous l'avez dit
c'est un procès minam en politique très
sulfureux bien évidemment le procès de
l'année vous avez même dit
l'opinion publique américaine elle va
dans quel sens je pense que l'opinion en
général et tout aussi divisés que notre
échiquier politique entre la gauche et
la droite
mais l'opinion des institutions
médiatiques des journalistes du parti
démocrate et de beaucoup d'autres
institutions d'autres organes puissants
et que des raids chauvin est coupable
ils veulent qu'il soit déclaré coupable
nous annonce que c'était un incident
fondée sur un motif de racisme que la
couleur de la personne a nommé son
arrestation et donc à sa mort il a
déclaré il ne sent alors je pense qu'il
faut se préparer à du chaos dans la rue
à des troubles
et s'il est déclaré coupable alors il y
aura également des manifestations c'est
très difficile à prédire
ce sujet politique et c'est un sujet
politique pour beaucoup de personnes
le pays est fortement fracturé entre
ceux qui pensent qu'ils devraient être
déclarés innocents et ceux qui le
croient coupable
merci chan uniquement d'avoir été avec
nous dans quelques instants reste avec
nous nous reviendrons sur l'application
tous sentis qu'ovide mise à jour
aujourd'hui pour stocker les preuves de
tester des attestations de vaccination
qui vont désormais être certifiés afin
de sécuriser les déplacements l'europe
et puis nous évoquerons la réputation en
ligne du gouvernement près de trois
millions d'euros ont été alloués à des
entreprises spécialisées dans la
stratégie numérique
[Musique]
il
vous êtes renversé par un homme de 92
ans qui perd le contrôle de son véhicule
deux ans et demi plus tard vous imposer
comme un espoir français du tennis
fauteuil objectif est les jeux
paralympiques de paris est vrai que le
sport m'a toujours sauver le tennis
c'est que c'est mon sport
bon il ya un fauteuil mais je vais
essayer en fait je me suis rendu compte
que ça allait c'était suffisamment
physique pour moi j'ai une vie de
sportif de haut niveau je m'entraîne
tous les jours c'est devenu ma vie la
raison de me lever le matin j'avais
toujours ce vieux rêve de petite fille
de faire du sport de ma vie est
finalement là c'est c'est ce que je
réalise avec le genre d'homme en avait
un autre combat on ma vie qui est celui
de la sécurité routière s'agit d'un
projet de loi qui vise à mettre en place
des tests d'aptitude pour tous les
conducteurs pas seulement les seniors on
a un contrôle technique de son véhicule
il faut un contrôle technique de sa
personne et sa l'état doit re doit
imposer loi sur ce sujet là
[Musique]
tous les jours des groupes de pression
remettent en cause notre pays au niveau
de son histoire et ne s'intéresse qu'au
présent pour eux la souveraineté
nationale ou populaire est inacceptable
car assimilés aux régimes dictatoriaux
ou à une vision dépassée de l'intérêt
national
d'un autre côté des élites nous
encourage abandonné l'idée de nation
française pour nous rallier à une robe
paré de toutes les vertus
malheureusement l'expérience montre que
si l'un des acteurs choisi de faire
cavalier seul en instaurant par exemple
des taxe protectionniste ou en mettant
en place des lois dissymétrique la
mondialisation se révèle un piège pour
tous les autres il faut avoir le courage
de faire le constat que l'europe à 27
noeuds permet de réaliser le vrai
consensus que sur des sujets mineurs ou
à la mode
[Musique]
il ya à peu près un enfant sur deux en
france qui est soit victime soit hauteur
de cyber violence sur internet un
contenu haineux de quelqu'un qui dit à
une fillette de 8 ans on va te suicider
ça ça doit être retirée immédiatement il
n'ya aucun débat à avoir sur son retrait
là parce que ça ça fait des suicides la
loi le condamne déjà c'est déjà interdit
de faire ça bien sûr mais c'est juste
que les gars fall de l'apli qu'à la
justice est lente et c'est très
problématique qui doit prendre ce rôle
de régulateur la loi peut aider
l'éducation peut aider selon les
différentes catégories d'attaquants et
d'attaquer une erreur de la loi via ça a
été de tout mettre dans le même panier
sous le sous le nom et no line quel rôle
pour les réseaux sociaux on a vu les big
for donc les gaffes à s'organiser pour
annuler quelqu'un sur internet ce
quelqu'un c'était donald trump quand il
s'agit d'un bannissement si général pour
moi ce n'est pas aux gaffes à et aux
réseaux sociaux à dublin des entreprises
privées de prendre cette décision mais
ça doit être à la justice de prendre
cette décision
[Musique]
vraiment
bonsoir à tous merci de nous rejoindre
pour cette deuxième émission tout de
suite voici les titres de l'actualité de
ce lundi 19 avril à ce sera désormais
difficile de se soustraire à tout senti
qu'ovide l'application de traçage des
malades du kobe des mises à jour ce
lundi
elle pourra intégrer un carnet
permettant de prouver le résultat
positif ou négatif d'un test de
détection du virus puis certifié l'état
vaccinal la france qui se protège face
aux variants et qui durcit ces règles
pour les voyageurs en italie c'est une
nouvelle au bout du tunnel restaurants
et établissements scolaires devraient
rouvrir lundi prochain malgré une
épidémie encore agressive
le chef du gouvernement mario draghi
exprimé un optimisme prudent face à un
risque calculé
le projet de réouverture s'appuie sur
deux piliers le maintien en toutes
circonstances des gestes barrières et
l'accélération de la campagne de
vaccination à cuba c'est une page qui se
tourne celle de l'air castro c'est
aujourd'hui que raul castro 89 ans doit
partir à la retraite à l'issue du
7e congrès du parti communiste de cuba
l'actuel premier secrétaire du parti
doit sauf surprise céder son poste au
président de lille miguel diaz cannelle
après plus de six décennies au service
du castrisme
[Musique]
depuis octobre dernier elle s'appelle
tous sentis qu'ovide l'application de
traçage des malades du comique 19 évolue
à nouveau aujourd'hui pour se rapprocher
un peu plus de ce que souhaite la
commission européenne avec le pass
sanitaires on en parle tout de suite
avec estelle farges qui se trouve devant
le ministère de la santé bonsoir estelle
le gouvernement qui va tester je cite un
nouvel outil sanitaire intégré à
l'application tout senti qu vide
eh oui stéphanie est une toute nouvelle
fonctionnalité baptisée carmet a fait
son apparition dans l'application tout
sentier qu'ovide ce carnet elle servira
à stocker une version numérique de votre
test pcr ou antigénique concrètement
lorsque vous effectuerez un test pcr le
résultat négatif sera authentifié avec
une signature électronique se sont elles
ces fameux qr cas d'un que l'on retrouve
aussi sur les attestations de
déplacement le qr code sera présent sur
la version papier du test vous pourrez
alors à décider ou non de le rapatrier
dans l'application objectif pour le
gouvernement
lutter contre eux est les falsifications
le secrétaire d'état au numérique un qui
a tout de même précisé qu'il n'y avait
pas d'obligation à utiliser cette
fonctionnalité
la fais est d'expérimentation devrait
débuter ces prochains jours pour les
déplacements entre la france
métropolitaine et la corse où
elle et dom tom à terme vous l'avez dit
il sera aussi possible de présenter une
attestation certifiant de vaccination
via l'application tout senti qu vide
et justement estelle la vaccination où
en est-on après le flop de l'opération
astrazeneca hans
eh bien depuis à le 17 décembre 2020
plus de 17 millions de personnes ont
reçu au moins une injection du vaccin au
18 avril et 4 millions à 500 villes ont
reçu leur seconde dose soit 8 6% de la
population majeure est la vaccination
est désormais ouverte en france au plus
de 55 ans sans comorbidités ce week-end
des créneaux de vaccination ont été
dédiés aux personnels à risque comme par
exemple les policiers ou les enseignants
de plus de 55 ans c'est le cas à nice et
vous l'évoquez stéphanie l'opération
elle n'a pas reçu le succès et compte
escompté puisque selon nos confrères de
france 3 ans seule une cinquantaine de
doses sur kate mille ont été administrés
faute de volontaires la réputation du
vaccin astrazeneca pourrait expliquer ce
manque d'engouement de son côté la
préfecture des alpes maritimes indique
que la population éligible dont la
région est réduite avec environ 3000
enseignants de plus de 55 ans et que la
communication est tardive autour de
cette opération ait pu influer sur la
participation et celle sur le front des
variants le gouvernement ces vies
et oui en 1500 euros damende c'est ce
qui attend lé voyageur en provenance du
brésil de l'argentine du chili où deux
d'afrique du sud qui ne respecteraient
pas la quarantaine à leur arrivée en
france annonce du porte-parole du
gouvernement
ce matin une amende qui pourrait monter
jusqu'à 3000 euros en cas de récidive
alors face à l'inquiétude que provoque
les variants du coffee de 19 comme par
exemple le variant brésilien le
gouvernement a décidé de rendre la
quarantaine obligatoire pour les
voyageurs en provenance de ces quatre
pays gelait rappelle brésil argentine et
chili ou afrique du sud un isolement de
dix jours avec des contrôles par la
police ou par la gendarmerie pour
vérifier que cet isolement est respectée
cette mesure s'appliquera pleinement à
partir du 24 avril et concernera aussi
la guyane merci estelle farges en direct
donc du ministère de la santé
et pour aller plus loin nous sommes avec
jean-françois timsit chef du service
réanimation médicale et infectieuse à
l'hôpital bichat bonsoir jean françois
timsit merci beaucoup d'être avec nous
en direct sur rt france on vient de
parler des variants est précisément le
conseil scientifique craint que le
variant brésilien deviennent
majoritaires cet été est ce que c'est
une hypothèse qui semble probable selon
vous il ya la conjonction de trois
choses qui joue un rôle un peu
inquiétant la première chose c'est que
la circulation du virus en france est
encore extrêmement élevé la deuxième
chose c'est que finalement le variant
anglais comme la un taux de reproduction
très élevé est certainement plus élevé
que le vin et le sud africain et variant
brésilien finalement ils contrôlent les
choses et comme le vaccin va être très
actif sur ce variant il va probablement
baisser et laisser de la place pour les
autres variant qui sont plus virulents
mais un petit peu moins contagieux comme
le variant brésilien vaillance d'afrique
donc ça c'est le deuxième point qui fait
un peu peur c'est de voir que finalement
comme
le variant brésilien est moins sensible
et moi le vaccin est moins efficace sur
ce variant brésilien et variant sud
africain eh bien on risque d'avoir
proportionnellement une montée de ce
type de variants par rapport aux
variants anglais qui a pris le dessus à
l'heure actuelle vous justement en tant
que médecin les mesures prises on en a
parlé avec estelle farges les
quarantaines les pcr ou obligatoire avec
des sanctions
est ce qu'elles sont suffisantes ou
c'est déjà trop tard
il était temps en tout cas il est clair
que du fait de la liberté individuelle
française et ce respect il ya eu
probablement assez peu de coercition taj
est bien fait il ya beaucoup de tests
disponibles mais le tracking était
vraiment trop basé sur le volontariat et
l' isolement était aussi trop basé sur
le volontariat d'autres pensent que par
le biais de la carte sanitaire on va
pouvoir probablement mieux tracé et
j'espère mieux isoler les cas et en
particulier ceux liés aux variants
brésiliens ou variante sud afrique par
exemple au royaume uni on a appris
aujourd'hui on va interdire aux
voyageurs venus d'inde où il ya un
variant dangereux aussi d'entrer tout
simplement sur son territoire ce sont
des mesures fermes
mais c'est ce qu'il faudrait qu'on fasse
également nous en france et
accessoirement l'europe
le problème c'est que les virus ils se
fichent complètement les frontières et
que s'il n'ya pas d'attitude mondiale
autour de ce contrôle de variants bailly
rentrera par un autre pays il y aura
toujours un pays où l'attitude sera plus
libre plus libéral et fera que le vario
passera par ailleurs on parle pas de
deux pays amis comme le portugal par
exemple où les liens entre le brésil et
le portugal sont importants heureusement
l'épidémie est faible au portugal mais
on peut imaginer que ce type de variants
puissent venir par par les pays qui
parle le portugais en europe donc voila
tout tout tout est un problème je pense
que en globalité
il est important de mieux tracer et de
mieux isoler les gens et de fournir les
capacités voir les capacités
d'hôtellerie nécessaire à ce que les
gens s'isole mieux alors c'est vrai
c'est particulièrement vrai pour les
nouveaux variants comme le vario
brésilien qui inquiète un peu mais c'est
aussi vrai pour l'ensemble des piles et
clairement tout le monde a le regard
tourné vers les débuts mélanie mais on
nous parle de réouverture vous pensez
que c'est quelque chose de crédible en
tout cas de souhaitable en tant que
médecin cette voie là cette libération
un petit peu à très attendue par les
français au début mais du point de vue
strictement sanitaire jeu quand même
très très inquiet quand on voit le
niveau de circulation virale malgré
quinze jours une attitude humble qu'on
peut appeler d'un compliment modeste et
de fermeture des écoles
j'ai du mal à croire qu'on atteigne un
niveau de circulation virale
suffisamment bas et un niveau de
vaccination suffisamment haut pour qu'on
puisse ouvrir largement qu'il y ait des
petites tentatives très localisées
d'ouverture de certaines petites choses
oui à croire qu'on va pouvoir tout
réouvriront mais honnêtement je pense
que ça serait prématuré et certainement
assez dangereux vous sur le terrain à
l'hôpital bichat
quelle est la situation par exemple le
niveau de saturation est maximale nous
avons à l'heure actuelle saturé
l'ensemble elie positif pour les
corvidés aussi beaucoup de malades qui
n'ont pas la copie qu'ils soient aussi
hospitalisée et à l'heure actuelle on
est vraiment absolument au niveau
maximal ce qu'il faut savoir c'est que
les malades sont très jeunes et quand
ils nécessitent de la réanimation en
particulier ils ont besoin de
ventilation mécanique ils ont besoin de
circulation extracorporelle pour
oxygéner le sens et leur durée de séjour
est de l'ordre de 4 à 5 semaines dans
ces cas là et donc à malade va occuper
50 40 à 50 journées d'hospitalisation en
soins critiques ce qui est considérable
c'est ce qu'on voit ici sur cette photo
qui apparaît à l'écran c'est circulation
extracorporelle et donc ça c'est
vraiment un grave problème parce que
c'est des gens qui sont très jeunes
on va pouvoir tirer de là mais pour
lequel il va falloir plus d'un mois de
réanimation intensive justement peu de
30000 contamination par jour c'est
beaucoup le virus circule évidemment
beaucoup trop l'école elle pas reprendre
dans une semaine
quel est votre sentiment lattier il ya
deux choses que je pense il faudrait
faire et très rapidement d'une part
vacciner l'ensemble du personnel
il faut savoir que les enfants
transmettre mais sont pas mal mais par
contre ils transmettent aux personnels
qui peuvent être malades et à son tour
transmettre
donc si vous pouvez déjà vacciner tout
le personnel et des écoles ce serait une
bonne chose
la deuxième chose qui est proposée par
le conseil scientifique depuis très
longtemps c'est d'assurer la circulation
de l'air dans
les classes avec des détecteurs de co2
qui permettent d'avoir une bonne
circulation de l'air si on calcule bien
et tout ce qui avait été proposé là
dessus depuis plusieurs mois n'a pas
encore été mis en place
je pense que ça manque cruellement avec
cette rentrée scolaire qui va être un
test tout à fait clés sur l'évolution de
l'épidémie en france
clairement docteur timsit on a un
sentiment toujours de courir après le
train est de ne jamais anticiper les
choses j'imagine que c'est certainement
votre sentiment sur sur le terrain
voulvoul attribué à quoi cette cette
lourdeur administrative que vous
rencontrez peut-être dans les hôpitaux à
la prise de décision au niveau du du
gouvernement vous avez une explication
vaud je pense qu'au niveau stricte
sommes strictement sanitaire je vous ai
dit ce qu'il en était effectivement on
aurait besoin de beaucoup plus que ça
après il ya tout un tas d'autres choses
pour lequel je suis pas compétent le
commerce e
l'activité économique actuelle du pays
le déficit
moi je ne suis pas compétent là dessus
donc je ne vais pas à donner mon avis là
dessus strictement sanitairement parlant
je pense qu'il faudrait un confinement
mieux respectés qu'à l'heure actuelle
une sortie d'école très progressive avec
des mesures relativement coercitives une
carte sanitaire très incitatif si elle
n'est pas coercitive pour arriver à
baisser les taux d'incidence dans le
pays à quatre cinq mille comme me
l'avait rapporté en septembre octobre de
façon à pouvoir ré ouvrir
progressivement à 30000 je vois pas bien
comment on va s'en sortir
merci jean françois timsit chef du
service réanimation médicale et
infectieuse à l'hôpital bichat paris
merci d'avoir été avec nous et sur les
réseaux sociaux à présent le
gouvernement investit pour gérer sa
réputation ligne près de trois millions
d'euros ont été alloués à des
entreprises spécialisées dans la
stratégie numérique un an de la
présidentielle
exécutif semble vouloir soigner son
image sur les réseaux sociaux décryptage
avec thomas bonnin s'il fallait une
preuve supplémentaire de la
prépondérance des réseaux sociaux dans
la prise de décision politique
la voici un appel d'offres lancé par le
service d'information du gouvernement en
décembre a été pourvue à la fin du mois
de mars sur la fiche disponible sur le
site officiel des annonces de marchés
publics
la mission est définie comme cela
l'accord cadre a pour objet la
fourniture d'outils de social listening
et de mesure d'impact sur les réseaux
sociaux pour permettre aux gouvernements
de détecter analyser et mesurer les
préoccupations et attentes des
internautes vis-à-vis de son action en
particulier et de l'actualité en général
un contrat à deux millions huit cent
mille euros répartis sur trois
entreprises une française et deux
étrangères le principe derrière la
notion de sochaux listening et d'obtenir
des données concernant les thématiques
les plus discutés sur les réseaux
sociaux
ensuite vient le temps de l'analyse vue
de l'adaptation de la stratégie à
adopter en misant autant d'argent pour
mesurer l'état d'esprit des internautes
français
le gouvernement montre qu'il y accorde
une importance croissante
cet investissement a été dénoncé par des
représentants politiques tels que
nicolas dupont aignan le député de
l'essonne estimant même qu'il s'agit
d'une forme de contrôle des libertés sur
les plateformes numériques
rien n'indique concrètement ce que le
gouvernement fera des données
recueillies par les entreprises
missionné adapter son discours et son
positionnement peut-être censuré et
riposter rien n'est moins sûr
mais les précédentes décisions de
l'exécutif concernant les réseaux
sociaux ont de quoi créer l'inquiétude
la controversée loi avia a beau avoir
été retoqué par le conseil
constitutionnel
un certain nombre de dispositifs se sont
finalement retrouvés dans le projet de
loi séparatisme et puis le premier
ministre déplore toujours l'anonymat en
ligne qu'il compare avec le régime de
vichy
rien que ça en dépensant du temps et de
l'argent pour sonder l'opinion en ligne
le gouvernement prend en tout cas le
risque de recevoir une vision biaisée
les réseaux sociaux n'étant pas ce qu'on
peut qualifier d'outils représentatif de
l'ensemble de la société française des
cas cela ne tienne la campagne 2022 sera
connecté ou ne sera pas d'ailleurs le
tournant 2.0 a déjà commencé puisque à
défaut de journalistes à l'ancienne le
gouvernement se tourne de plus en plus
vers les influenceurs et les youtuber
pour la plupart plus malléable afin de
diffuser la bonne parole
oui pour en parler nous sommes avec
fabrice epelboin spécialiste des réseaux
sociaux enseignant à sciences po paris
bonsoir fabrice epelboin merci d'être
avec nous que vous inspire ce dessin cet
objectif du gouvernement de vouloir
s'acheter entre guillemets à investir en
tout cas pour sa réputation sur les
réseaux sociaux
surveiller sa réputation sur la l2
sociaux c'est quelque chose que la
plupart des grandes entreprises font
depuis belle lurette et de très
nombreuses étapes font également ça nous
pourrons plus de vous dire que dans ce
domaine là le gouvernement c'est plutôt
un peu en retard et qui serait temps que
les six mètres plutôt que d'extrapoler
des théories farfelues sur la moindre
phénomène qui qui se fait jour
quotidiennement sur les réseaux sociaux
alors évidemment on entend les critiques
ici ou là insiste m
voilà qui s'apparente à une surveillance
des réseaux sociaux on voir un contrôle
des libertés vous souscrivez sur biron
des réseaux sociaux absolument c'est le
but de ces outils
en ce qui concerne la liberté ce ne sont
pas ces outils qui vous permet de
censurer quoi que ce soit ces outils
sont faits pour regarder ce qui se passe
analyser ce qui se passe et essaie de
comprendre l'effet de mettre d'opinion
qu'on peut observer dans les réseaux
sociaux qui il faut le rappeler ne sont
pas un reflet absolu et fidèle de la
réalité de ce qui se passe dans
l'opinion publique qu'elle est
clairement la marge de manoeuvre du
gouvernement pour surveiller ces réseaux
sociaux dans la mesure où il n'a
certainement pas accès aux outils de la
haine et sa balle elle mal de manoeuvres
aller à aller dans l'utilisation
d'outils de monitoring et de
surveillance qui sont les mêmes outils
qu'utilisent les gains des grandes
multinationales pour surveiller leur
réputation adapter leurs communications
réagir de façon appropriée à une crise
et essayer de comprendre l'effet de leur
communication sur l'opinion publique à
travers l'analyse qui est offert en
quasiment en temps réel sur les réseaux
sociaux
et quelle est la bonne marge de
manoeuvre surtout pour réagir une fois
qu'on a surveillé
et qu'on a établi un diagnostic comment
peut-on réagir parce que on le sait
maintenant tant qu'individus et
extrêmement compliqué compris compliqué
pardon de supprimer un contenu
alors pour réagir il a deux méthodes la
méthode première c'est la communication
classique c'est à prendre en compte la
le reflet que donne une herbe une
opération de communication dans les
réseaux sociaux est-elle adaptée et puis
ils allaient les fameuses équipe riposte
c'est à dire des militants ou des gens
payés pour ça qu'on va mobiliser de
façon à disséminer la bonne parole ou
attaquer une parole qui dérange ses
équipes riposte ont été mises à jour il
ya de ça plusieurs années maintenant par
samuel laurent journaliste du monde qui
a montré qu' il y avait plusieurs
équipes riposte dans l'entourage de la
république en marché dans l'entourage ou
l'exécutif ainsi que de nombreux
parlementaires qui au besoin aller
porter la bonne parole mais surtout
attaqué notamment des journalistes comme
samuel laurent qui a défié la bonne
parole du gouvernement
en prenant le pouls justement sur ces
réseaux sociaux comme l'expliqué thomas
bonnet est ce que cela ne risque-t-il
pas d'apporter une vision biaisée
finalement de la société si on prend ce
qu'on mesure au premier degré oui bien
sûr ce qui existe sur les réseaux
sociaux n'est pas le reflet de l'opinion
publique par contre si on commence à
comprendre cette déformation qui existe
entre l'opinion publique et son reflet
dans les réseaux sociaux non c'est
plutôt un très bon outil pour arriver à
faire quelque part de la mesure
d'opinion en temps réel vais évidemment
il faut prendre du recul avec les
chiffres bruts
il faut vraiment toujours bien pensé
qu'on a affaire à une projection que
tout ne se projette pas typiquement la
barre et aux rites et silencieuse ne va
pas par définition se projeter et les
mouvements de contestation vont prendre
une place disproportionnée sur les
réseaux sociaux
si on garde ses éléments en tête ça
reste un excellent outil pour mesurer
l'opinion publique est ce que ces outils
sont des outils d'avenir pour la
politique selon vous assez des outils
d'avenir c'est des outils même du passé
j'ai envie de dire beaucoup beaucoup de
gouvernements ont déjà adopté ce type
d'outil de façon à comprendre comment se
développe l'opinion publique pour
pouvoir réagir de façon gratuite et
agile 2022 va-t-il se jouer en grande
partie sur les réseaux sociaux
c'est très probable essentiellement
parce que au bout on parle de luile 22
s'annonce comme un duel très serré entre
marine le pen et emmanuel macron très
serré au sens de quelques pourcents
hélas les réseaux sociaux qui peuvent
avoir un impact sur ces quelques
pourcents peuvent avoir un rôle
absolument majeur les réseaux sociaux y
avait très peu de rôles à la précédente
élection parce que le décalage entre les
intentions de vote sur marine le pen et
celle sur emmanuel macron était très
large donc c'est pas les réseaux sociaux
qui aurait fait basculer en faveur de
l'un ou l'autre candidat
mes larmes ça danse ça s'annonce comme
étant très serrés et pour le coup les
réseaux sociaux pourrait faire toute la
différence
merci fabrice epelboin spécialiste des
réseaux sociaux enseignant à sciences po
paris merci d'avoir été avec nous et
dans le reste de l'actualité les
voyageurs en prononce aux dindes
interdit de séjour au royaume uni en
cause la flambée de kobe 19 ans dans le
gouvernement indien
annoncé aujourd'hui la vaccination anti
qu'ovide sera ouverte à tous les adultes
à partir du mois de mai le pays et
confine dans la région de new delhi
nouvelle vague qui n'épargne pas la
jeunesse valentin carpentier et sa radio
nous savons que cette nouvelle vague de
coville est très dangereuse et nos
jeunes sont plutôt sérieusement affecté
par cette nouvelle vague
les jeunes nouvelles victimes majeures
du virus en inde dans le plus grand
hôpital de new delhi réservé aux
patients qui ont contracté le qu'ovide
huit enfants de moins de 12 ans ont été
admis dont un bébé de huit mois selon
les derniers bilans réaliser 65% des
nouveaux patients ont moins de 45 ans
oui certains jours étaient pires que
d'autres des jours où j'avais une
sérieuse douleurs à la poitrine
incapable de proprement respirer comme
de voir s'allonger en position de
pronation ce qui m'aidait à respirer
parce que mon nez était bouché oui ces
jours là je me disais que mon heure
était peut-être venu c'est une pensée
sinistre à avoir mais c'est ce que je
pense à des médecins détectent même des
symptômes encore jamais vu chez les
jeunes touchés lors de la première vague
ce que nous constatons et ce n'est
qu'une anecdote est une expérience
personnelle c'est que des patients plus
jeunes sont admis à l'hôpital et sont
plus malades que le type de maladie dont
souffre habituellement les jeunes
patients qui est léger à modéré
dans certains cas nous voyons deux
jeunes patients souffrant même de ce que
l'on appelle une maladie critique où ils
ont besoin de grandes quantités
d'oxygène ou sont sous respirateur
avec plus de 15 millions de cas positifs
l'inde est le deuxième pays le plus
touché au monde derrière les etats unis
les autorités ont recensé ce lundi un
nouveau record
près de deux cent soixante treize mille
huit cents nouvelles contaminations en
l'espace de vingt-quatre heures au
brésil les états de sao paulo et rio
commencent à lever les restrictions
sanitaires
une décision qui ne fait pas l'unanimité
plus de soixante six mille morts ont été
recensés au mois de mars et le variant
brésilien force certains pays du monde à
imposer des quarantaines aux voyageurs
en provenance du pays est détaillé avec
avaya souple et des images pour le moins
surprenante à sao paulo ce dimanche les
habitants ont pu voir les commerces et
les lieux de culte rouvrir pourtant le
brésil est toujours le deuxième pays le
plus endeuillé au monde et le nouveau
vaillant brésilien représente la
majorité des contaminations recensés sur
le territoire au mois de mars
la raison de cet assouplissement des
restrictions selon les autorités locales
le taux d'occupation dans les unités de
soins intensifs est passé sous la barre
des 90% et nouvelles infections sont
également en baisse un bilan qui a
conduit l'état à passer en phase orange
un choix difficilement justifiable selon
domingo alves chercheurs de la faculté
de médecine de l'université de sao paulo
c'est lamentable qu'on annonce serré
ouverture alors que tout indique que la
semaine prochaine ou celle d'après nous
allons manquer de médicaments pour
l'incubation de patients au programme de
cette réouverture progressive des
commerces
ouvert de 11h à 19h avec une jauge de 25
% d'occupation les mais ces offices
religieux sont également soumis à des
mesures sanitaires strictes
le couvre feu de 20h à 5h du matin est
maintenu nouvelle étape le 24 avril
prochain
les autorités prévoient la réouverture
des restaurants institut de beauté
cinéma et théâtre une phase de
transition jugé utile pour certains est
trop précipité pour d'autres sortir dans
un espace ouvert pour voir qu'ils
prennent toutes les précautions
c'était très radicale de garder tous les
commerces fermés évidemment on ne peut
pas revenir à ce que c'était mais ouvrir
avec toutes les précautions je pense que
c'était le moment je pense que la
réouverture est un peu précipité puisque
le virus est là et que les unités de
soins intensifs sont toujours bondée le
manque de médicaments pour plusieurs
procédures et les gens vont voir cela
comme une détente apportant une nouvelle
contamination
[Musique]
depuis une semaine rio de janeiro a
également allégé ces restrictions
bars et restaurants ont pu rouvrir leurs
portes
même si l'interdiction de fréquenter les
plages et maintenu un retour en douceur
à la vie normale qui reste décriée dans
un pays où la situation épidémique est
toujours hors de contrôle reste avec
nous dans quelques instants nous
parlerons de l'allègement des
restrictions sanitaires dans plusieurs
pays européens cette fois qui regroupe
une vie normale en italie c'est prévu
pour dans une semaine avec la
réouverture des restaurants et des
abysses et établissements scolaires
et puis direction cuba où une page se
tourne celle de l'air castro
[Musique]
la crise du côté de 19 à semble-t-il
mise en lumière lippert mondialisation
et les contraintes qui vont avec
démondialiser pas sur un coup de
baguette magique ça coûte cher de
relocaliser il faut aussi changer ce
pourquoi les entreprises sont partis il
ya de grandes passions de le voir et qui
implique des stratégies qui sont
complètement différentes
vous pouvez essayer de refaire venir de
la vieille industrie qui a disparu ou
des secteurs qui ont disparu mais s'ils
ont disparu il ya une vieille a une
bonne raison
l'autre façon de voir c'est de savoir
quels sont les nouveaux secteurs
auxquels sont les secteurs l'avenir
qu'on peut arriver à conserver chez nous
si un jour on veut re localiser et bien
il faut déjà empêché les cerveaux de
partir ou en tous cas lors donner des
moyens pour qu'ils aient envie de rester
il n'y a pas une façon plus pauvres de
défendre un système que de dire qu'il
est moins pire qu'un autre le peuple
c'était une volonté collective
vous le savez comme moi que dès qu'on
dit il n'y a pas d'alternative on sort
du politique
il est clair que tout le monde attend ça
est-ce que c'est grave
est ce que c'est normal si on veut
sauver la vie sur terre il est probable
qu'il faille prendre un certain nombre
de mesures un peu autoritaire c'est
intéressant on comprend que vous soyez
des sous les libéraux l'uniforme c'est
quand même des hommes comment ces
mecs-là arrive à dormir la nuit là aussi
je pense qu'on a vécu quelque chose
d'inusité gilet jaune c'était des
valeurs de droite
c'était des gens qui travaillent c'est
les gens qui avaient envie de
transmettre quelque chose à leurs
enfants qui
tout
le droit il doit éviter les dérives
idéologiques merci de le souligner
comment peut-on reconstituer une sixième
république qui ne soit pas l'oublié
parlementaire ça se passe en direct
puisque on est en direct il ya quand
même la liberté
je vous remercie de m'avoir invité
[Musique]
tous les jours des groupes de pression
remettent en cause notre pays au niveau
de son histoire et ne s'intéresse qu'au
présent pour eux la souveraineté
nationale ou populaire est inacceptable
car assimilés aux régimes dictatoriaux
ou à une vision dépassée de l'intérêt
national
d'un autre côté des élites nous
encourage abandonné l'idée de nation
française pour nous rallier à une robe
paré de toutes les vertus
malheureusement l'expérience montre que
si l'un des acteurs choisi de faire
cavalier seul en instaurant par exemple
des taxe protectionniste ou en mettant
en place des lois dissymétrique la
mondialisation se révèle un piège pour
tous les autres il faut avoir le courage
de faire le constat que l'europe à 27
noeuds permet de réaliser le vrai
consensus que sur des sujets mineurs ou
à la mode
[Musique]
oh
21h38 les bienvenus en direct sur rt
france allègement des restrictions
sanitaires dans plusieurs pays européens
des pays qui regoûte peu à peu à une vie
normale comme la suisse le danemark mais
aussi vous allez voir la belgique et le
portugal avec la réouverture des écoles
et des centres commerciaux pour les
belges se sont les frontières qui rouvre
mais sous condition emilie gogh h depuis
fin janvier
il était impossible de franchir les
frontières belges sans motif impérieux
en raison de la pandémie
une interdiction arrivée à son terme
dimanche soir les déplacements depuis et
vers l'étranger reste déconseillé par
les autorités mais les belges peuvent à
nouveau se rendre dans les aéroports ou
les gares pour voyager au sein de
l'union européenne à moi je suis très
heureux parce que ma petite fille arrive
antalis de paris et jeux les plus vus
depuis très longtemps avec ce
confinement et donc c'est une très très
bonne chose ça permet peine de pouvoir
profiter tout en étant dans les règles
et en essayant de limiter un maximum pas
la propagation du président pour laisser
le temps à la population d'être vacciné
les cafés et restaurants fermés depuis
octobre n'ouvriront pas leurs terrasses
avant le 8 mai c'est aussi le retour à
l'école pour les belges ce lundi les
vacances de pâques sont terminés une
semaine avant qu'elles ne commencent
seules les écoles maternelles étaient
ouvertes même assouplissement au
portugal entrez dans la troisième phase
d'un déconfinement progressif commencé
il y à plus d'un mois résultat les
lycées et les universités ouvrent leurs
portes tout comme les centres
commerciaux les cafés et restaurants
accueillent des clients mais avec un
nombre limité et des horaires restreints
cela me manquait déjà je vais bientôt
partir en voyage à l'étranger
donc je dois acheter des vêtements cette
réouverture arrive au bon moment on ne
peut pas voyager sans vêtements de plus
ça me manque aussi de pouvoir m'asseoir
et prendre un café et quelque chose à
manger
on se remet au boulot on a nos clients
qui arrivent on remet la maison en
marche car cela fait trois mois que l'on
était fermée sans rien pouvoir faire
on espère que cela va durer on va tout
faire pour c'est important d'avoir pu
réussir à arriver jusqu'ici
on va voir ce que le futur nous réserve
ce n'est pas impossible que l'on doive
confiné mais nous ne devons pas tomber
dans une joie excessive et les gens
doivent continuer à se comporter
raisonnablement les salles de spectacle
et les cinémas reprennent aussi leurs
activités le portugal a vécu un
confinement national de deux mois pour
endiguer une importante troisième vague
épidémique
ils avancent petit à petit vers un
retour à la vie normale
dernière étape de ce déconfinement le 3
mai et en italie toujours sur le front
du coc vite c'est également une nouvelle
lueur au bout du tunnel restaurants et
établissements scolaires devrait rouvrir
lundi prochain le chef du gouvernement
mario draghi exprimé vendredi dernier un
optimisme prudent face à un risque
calculé bien que le nombre de décès soit
d'environ 300 personnes par jour le
nombre de contagion a reculé de 15 %
pour s'établir à environ 12000 quatre
quotidiens et pour en parler nous sommes
donnés combertault giovannini médecins
chirurgiens bon soin envers tôt giovanni
merci d'être avec nous alors les
italiens qui on imagine ont le sentiment
de voir le bout du tunnel où il reste
quand même très prudent on voit que
l'épidémie frappe toujours beaucoup
l'italie oui bonsoir mais disons que
mcelhinney wilson une traîne db c'est
surtout les taux d occupation des
réactions b c et il faut dire aussi
qu'ils donnent une très gros espoirs sur
la campagne du mac c'est qui au début
battait parents d'élèves et la moins
d'avril
on a mieux réorganiser la vaccination on
s'est focalisé plus sur le personnes
âgées les systèmes aussi des
réservations de l'accès des vaccinations
était plus performant et on a
l'impression que les choses aient roulé
un peu mieux
un rapport tous les cafouillages qui ont
eu de pertes dans les périodes d dès
janvier-février qui a mené aussi à la
démission du premier ministre compte
donc on a l'impression communes ont mis
plus d'ordre après la compétence
d'harcourt et qui étaient les chefs
intrus mais des guerres a très bien
parlé des matrones d'abord comme byd qui
est donc c'était la personne qui
organise et l'achat des marasquer tous
les vaccinations en d'intérêt très bien
perdre comme idée finalement de on a
découvert qu'il est pas mal de
désorganisation et là on a le sentiment
que les choses se compliquent droite
mais aussi dont les gens ils ont mis à
prix aussi à faire les gestes barrière
donc en petit à petit les gens dans
l'intérêt aussi c'est qu'il faut faire
pour en éviter les propager là vous vous
dites que vous vous dites oui on a le
sentiment mais enfin malheureusement la
science sont des chiffres 300 personnes
par jour qui décède pour s'établir à
environ 12 mille cas quotidiens
également saraste des chiffres élevés
vous en tant que médecin vous trouvez ça
je ce mot raisonnable de baisser la
garde sur les restrictions où il ya un
moment il faut tout simplement choisir
aussi la liberté parce que les gens n'en
peuvent plus mais disons qu'on commence
à voir aussi des problèmes à des
souffrances psychologiques
donc ça aussi c'est prendre un camp
parce qu'il s'est montré moins plus
intrigué vraiment une spécialité comme
on dit la chirurgie plastique s'est
adonné les années à la vie mais c'est
donner la vie aux années donc je voulais
aussi les problèmes de l'équipe doit
effectivement il faut le faire tout le
possible pour contenir la propagation du
virus
permettre aux hôpitaux des gares des
chocs et départ être submergé par un
afflux trop une porte du patient ça
reste encore des problèmes in italy sur
la médecine de ville et c'est assez je
pense que c'est vraiment les tâches il
est amical y met de côté aussi forte
demande au niveau économique social et
la détention qui se monte il ya eu des
émeutes
et ça aussi draghi il a entendu aussi la
souffrance des italiens appellent les
parties d'agir c'est les progressions de
libéraux qu'ils ont ils ont quelque peu
d'elle mais globalement qu'ils ont
beaucoup souffert des points de vue
économique de cette pandémie avec des
activités qui sont art est à l'arrêt
depuis un an avec quelques airs et arty
mais globalement les gens ils ont perdu
leur chiffre d'affaires entre 20 et 80 %
donc c'est sûr qu'il faut trouver un
équilibre un truc tout ça si moi je le
vois par rapport à mes fils l'écologie
l'italie c'est la grosse ou phrase parce
qu'un phrase d'un cran à lessines écoute
qu'elle coûte que l'école reste et
bertal en italie on peut dire que les
enfants ça fait et nantes qui font
l'école à distance donc ils voient pas
leur lorsque opel donc ça aussi on a
décidé d ouvrir l'école au moins pour le
dernier les voir que les gens puissent
aussi avoir un côté de bien social
forcément c'est toujours un équilibre
entre ouvrir un peu les vannes sans ses
fers adam leur départ nouvelle tous et
une nouvelle vague et des copines aussi
la souffrance des parents qui ont leurs
enfants la maison depuis un an et qui
doit faire école
c'est sûr que ça doit pas être évident
l'italie qui enquêtent sur un haut
responsable de l'om est également
soupçonné d'avoir fait disparaître un
rapport est-ce que clairement on
commence à chercher également les
coupables sur la mauvaise gestion de la
crise oui oui ça c'est sûr comme je
disais on me manque les conduire le
parti notionnels est la vraie émergence
et communs ceux peu retombé aussi rend
compte que la gestion d'harcourt y était
quand même très calamiteuse là on parle
aussitôt de ben ça pour le mans c'est
juste de parler donc il ya toujours un
truc d'innocence mais c'est qu'on peut
regarder c'est effectivement il y a eu
des des moments sur la campagne de
vaccination les masques des au début il
ya eu des moments forts de cette
pandémie
ou les personnes qui étaient aux
manettes
ils n'ont pas pris les bonnes décisions
donc c'est sûr que l'on a on a payé un
prix encore plus élevés du fait que des
visions était pas bon alors mais non il
faut comprendre
est-ce qu'ils n'étaient pas bonnes pour
les compétences moi j'arrête ou patronal
géopolitique mais c'est vrai ici aussi
une italie il ya beaucoup de partis
populistes et pas forcément déjà un très
brillant et très pointu qui sont aux
manettes du gouvernement et de l'autre
côté aussi
c'est ce qu'ils n'ont pas après les
décisions parce qu'il ya eu des dépôts
de bennes donc qui est du côté un train
plus grave on commence à voir des
réflexions par rapport à tout ça merci
berthod giovannini médecin chirurgie en
italie nous avoir exposé justement la
situation de votre pays merci à vos
derniers jours de règne à la tête du
parti communiste cubain pour raul castro
à 89 ans il met fin à six décennies
pouvoir des frères castro après avoir
succédé à fidel alors est ce la fin
d'une ère pour cuba c'est ce que nous
allons voir avec florian lambert une
journée désormais historique à cuba raul
castro 89 ans et derniers frères castro
à la tête du pays laisse place à une
nouvelle génération après six décennies
de règne castris président de la
république
miguel diaz cannelle 60 ans a pris la
succession ce lundi comme premier
secrétaire du parti communiste et
devient ainsi le premier civil à diriger
également le parti dans lequel il aura
fait toute sa carrière
un passage de témoin historique et
décisif dans une période de crise pour
cuba en pleine pandémie est sous la
pression des sanctions américaines
renforcées durant le mandat de donald
trump lors du 8ème congrès du parti
raul castro a d'ailleurs fait le voeu de
voir se développer de nouvelles
relations avec les états unis après des
décennies de conflit sous l'ère
castriste jeu ratifie depuis ce congrès
du parti
la volonté de développer un dialogue
respectueux et de construire un nouveau
type de relations avec les états unis
sans l'intention que cuba renonce aux
principes de la révolution et du
socialisme pour y parvenir
tant que je vivrai je serai prêt le pied
à l'étrier à défendre la patrie la
révolution et le socialisme avec plus de
force que jamais
crions vivait combat libre et la fin
d'une époque pour plus de 11 millions de
cubains beaucoup d'entre eux n'auront
jamais connu d'autres dirigeants que les
frères castro
là je crois que la position de raul
castro de donner un chemin pour la
continuité dans la direction du parti a
été très importante
après avoir développé un travail louable
à la tête du parti communiste de cuba
je pense que le fait que d'autres
générations se joignent à la direction
du parti est une bonne chose il y avait
encore sa pensée et c'est très positif
de donner de l'espace pour d'autres
générations de diriger le parti
au canada c'est à la fois l'impact et je
pense que la décision de prendre sa
retraite est la bonne
nous devons céder la place aux jeunes il
a plusieurs ministres miguel diaz
cannelle au sein de l'état ils ont la
capacité de diriger le pays
de toute évidence c'est un personnage
public un personnage important de la
révolution de l'histoire de notre pays
parce que depuis des années il a été un
personnage important à l'heure actuelle
depuis que fidel castro a quitté la
présidence il a bien assumé ce rôle
babel miguel jazz cannelle fidèles
partisans du castrisme ne devrait pas
révolutionner la ligne politique cubaine
actuelle face aux pénuries de produits
de première nécessité due à la pandémie
de covin 19 une vague de contestation
monte dans le pays
porté par une nouvelle génération de
cubains qui s'empare des réseaux sociaux
accessibles depuis peu sur l'île
miguel diaz cannes elle aura sans doute
à faire une jeunesse plus
revendicatrices que celle de l'air
castriste et pour en parler nous sommes
avec stéphane witkowski merci d'être
avec nous en direct franc et sauf si
spécialiste de que de cuba clairement
peut-on dire que c'est la fin d'une
époque
je dirais que c'est une date symbolique
mais qui étaient déjà préparés de très
longue date puisque en réalité il ya
liesse crennel qui a pris le premier
secrétariat du parti et avait été déjà
été président du conseil d'état en 2018
il avait été élu président de la
république en 2019 et il est temps déjà
en fonction depuis trois ans et ce
processus est une processus de
transition générationnelle
mais d'aucune manière une transition
politique car il y avait aussi une
réforme de la nouvelle constitution qui
avaient été validées par les cubains qui
avaient été amendés discuté par les
cubains mal an entre 2019 et qui avait
un peu modifié l'équilibré
institutionnel et politique
donc c'est une nouvelle date je dirais
symboliquement importante pour raul
castro lui-même qui était déjà encore
une fois prévu mais qui s'inscrit pour
ce qu'on appelle le
l'institutionnalisation de la révolution
et donc les objectifs de la révolution
de moeurs il ya pas changement sur ce
plan est en revanche je dirais que la
feuille de route qui a été clairement
indiquée par raul castro lors de son
discours il ya deux jours définit
surtout des objectifs économiques et
sociaux extrêmement important et en
maintenant le cap par rapport à les fils
défi majeur qui est la relation avec les
états unis
les défis les plus importants c'est
d'abord le l'unification monétaire qui a
été déjà été initiée depuis le 1er
janvier et qui est un défi qui posent
des questions à la fois technique
sociétaux et politiques
il ya un deuxième objectif économique
important c'est de réduire la dépendance
agro alimentaire et énergétique de l'île
qui très dépendants de l'étranger
et puis aussi il ya évidemment d'autres
défis un peu plus de moyens en terme
d'aidé fille démographique puisque la
société cubaine est de plus en plus âgée
et c'est la contrepartie d'une une de la
qualité d'une médecine qui est
importante et l'informatisation de la
société qui sur lequel l'actuel
président a mis l'accent pour vraiment
informatisé la société d'autant que d'un
ingénieur de formation et il souhaite
effectivement que la société cubaine
soit 13 informatisé alors la
contrepartie c'est effectivement ce que
dit votre documentaire c'est que il ya
effectivement une société civile qui est
de plus en plus éveillés qu'a formé à
l'as truite de toute façon parce qu'il
ya un très haut niveau de formation à à
cuba mais évidemment cette société en
particulier cette génération des 20 45
ans à peu près qui a un très haut niveau
de formation qui souhaiteraient avoir
des débouchés professionnels et des
salaires
et qui correspondent à leurs à leur
formation effectivement pardonnez-moi
ses défis ses présidents actuels amis
guen audience au pénal qui va devoir
voilà les affronter les mener à bien
qui est il cet homme c'est un civil donc
il ya une soixantaine d'années qui n'est
après la révolution
un ingénieur de formation qui a été lui
même je dirais je dirais très très au
fait de du monde holly 13 très
intéressés par la question culture de
musique
son épouse est elle-même dirige
l'institut en matière de deux questions
de formation culturelle
il est lui-même amateur de musique
heurts particuliers de dd piquionne il
est toujours là toujours son portable
donc il est très moderne ça dans sa
façon d'être sa dalle très pragmatique
nomme très concret un homme très prudent
qui s'impliquent dans les dossiers et
depuis qu'il est président il a vraiment
suivi les différents dossiers et il a
réussi dans un profil je lirai très
différente ses prédécesseurs de manière
très très calme de poser des problèmes
sans langue de bois et sans discours
idéologique particulier et en essayant
d'être au plus proche du terrain
alors évidemment les dix travaillent de
plus en plus une manière collégiale ici
probablement une des modifications
majeures depuis la nouvelle constitution
il ya un premier ministre aussi et il ya
aussi une volonté grâce aussi d'une
diplomatie cubaine qui est extrêmement
professionnelle et très aguerris face à
je dirais une contrainte américaine
nord-américaine depuis 60 ans qui est
effectivement est particulièrement dur
et en particulier dans la période
récente avec les 250 mesures à deux
départs par trump et cet embargo qui
perdure et qui est une anomalie dans le
monde international
car au fond rien ne pourra vraiment
considérablement évolué sur le plan
intérieur à cuba en tout cas par rapport
au système économique et politique tant
que la normalisation avec des états unis
notamment et qu'il dépende de conditions
la levée de l'embargo mais qui dépend de
la levée de l'embargo ses deux fils qui
dépend du congrès puisque vous savez ici
plus loi menant aux états unis pour le
clan gbagbo
il ya un deuxième élément c'est la
restitution de la base de guantanamo qui
est une anomalie qui est une portion de
territoire cubaine une chance de
templeuve étrangères sur le territoire
cubain est évidemment cuba peut
s'appuyer sur un réseau international
extrêmement développer la solidarité
internationale les pays
évidemment à bolivarien c'est à dire les
pays régionaux nicaragua venezuela en
particulier et des grands pays comme la
russie la chine l'inde nature qui est là
l'essentiel des pays africains
l'essentiel des paysages ya tic auxquels
s'ajoutent aussi un accord cadre de
coopération politique avec l'union
européenne
donc je dirais que cuba n'est d'aucune
manière
seule sur la scène internationale merci
stéphane invite ski président du conseil
d'orientation stratégique des hautes
études de l'amérique latine spécialiste
de cuba d'avoir été avec nous et dans le
reste de l'actualité la france porte une
lourde responsabilité dans le génocide
prévisible des tutsis en 1994 au rwanda
c'est la conclusion d'un rapport
commandé par les autorités rwandaises et
remis au président paul kagame ce lundi
est détaillé avec robin pu l
la france une nouvelle fois pointé du
doigt pour son rôle dans le génocide des
tutsi au rwanda
une enquête menée par un cabinet
d'avocats américain à la demande des
autorités rwandaises estime que la
france a rendu possible le génocide qui
a coûté la vie à près de huit cent mille
personnes en 1994
c'est la deuxième fois en moins d'un
mois que l'attitude du gouvernement
français de l'époque est remise en cause
tout comme le rapport duclair remis à
emmanuel macron le cabinet d'avocats n'a
pas pu produire de preuves de la
complicité des responsables français
mais leur apport mu publié ce lundi
semble plus sévère que la commission
d'historiens français vis-à-vis de
l'implication de paris seul l'état
français a été un collaborateur
indispensable dans l'établissement
d'institutions qui deviendraient des
instruments du génocide
aucun autre état étranger n'avait
connaissance du danger représenté par
les extrémistes rwandais tout en
appuyant ces mêmes extrémistes lors du
pouvoir français a aidé singulier
pourtant l'état français n'a toujours
pas reconnu son rôle et ne s'en remet
toujours pas officiellement excusé le
rôle de la france est au coeur des
tensions diplomatiques entre paris et
kigali depuis 27 ans la normalisation
des rapports entre les deux pays était
l'une des motivations des manuels macron
lors de l'ouverture des archives de
l'elysée qui a permis la rédaction du
rapport du clair de son côté le
gouvernement rwandais salue la volonté
des deux pays d'avancer dans la même
direction
ces deux commissions d'analysé des faits
historiques analyser les archives qui
ont été mises à leur disposition et sont
parvenus à une compréhension commune de
se passer ce qui est très important
si vous avez une compréhension commune
du passé il est plus facile de
travailler ensemble pour construire un
avenir meilleur entre les deux pays
[Musique]
preuve du réchauffement des relations
entre les deux pays
le président rwandais paul kagamé
devrait être présent à paris le 18 mai
prochain dans le cadre d'un sommet sur
le financement des économies africaines
emmanuel macron a également l'intention
de se rendre au rwanda au cours de la
et une visite déterminante dans un pays
qui attend depuis 27 ans la fin du déni
français en république centrafricaine de
nombreuses femmes subissent des
violences notamment sexuelles certaines
sont prises en charge par médecins sans
frontières d'autres en revanche à vivre
avec la peur d'être exclu de leur
communauté ou d'être stigmatisés et
continue à se cacher pas comme pas
toujours dit avec martial plus avions
c'est un week end ordinaire pour les
femmes centrafricaines dans la capitale
bangui elles sont nombreuses à faire les
courses l'air de rien et pourtant
nombreuses garde en elle les séquelles
d'une guerre qui dure depuis déjà près
de dix ans les violences physiques et
sexuelles font partie du quotidien de
certaines de ces femmes et pour leur
venir en aide
l' ong médecins sans frontières a lancé
ce samedi 17 avril un programme de prise
en charge la situation gilera des
victimes qui viennent vers nous
effectivement s ont volé dans une étape
très inquiétant parce que vous savez que
l'union c'est un acte horrible
automatique et tous les régimes qui
viennent dé renom sont souvent très
traumatisée et dès qu'ils sont élus
verts bompard à notre secours notre
appui on a vu qu'il ya vraiment eu un
changement radical dans le
depuis juillet
jusqu'à fin moment qu'on va dire nous
avons reçu de 174 personnes
majoritairement des femmes
aussi cette robe est
24 mineurs en général pas dans un très
beau d'état puisque
violetta fin et psychologique
c'est une violence
d
souvent dans un contexte de nous
menaces
si lui et rose font partie de ces
victimes de violences sexuelles
un visage couvert elles ont accepté de
témoigner
j'étais reparti chez moi en 2013 pour
prendre des affaires pour mon bébé et
des musulmans armés du pk5 compris au
coucher avec moi avant d'enfoncer un
bâton dans nos sexes je ne connaissais
personne parmi eux je n'ai pu porter l
affaire en justice je suis seulement
venu ici à l'hôpital
[Musique]
c'était le 11 décembre 2013 que cela
m'est arrivé
ce sont des scellés cas qui sont arrivés
en grand nombre dans un véhicule en
tirant dans toutes les directions
le mari de ma grande soeur avaient fui
ma grande soeur en les entendant aussi a
fui j'ai été tourmenté par les tirs et
lorsque j'ai essayé de fuir ils m'ont
pris ils m'ont violée et ont pillé la
maison en prenant de l'argent et des
téléphones ils ont tout ramasser et ont
fait plusieurs tirs avant de partir
toujours d'après médecins sans
frontières il est fréquent que les
agressions soient commises par des
personnes appartenant à l'entourage des
victimes
plus de la moitié des personnes prises
en charge déclarent connaître leurs
agresseurs et c'est la fin de cette
émission merci de l'avoir suivi prochain
point sur l'actualité avec emilie goog h
dans quelques minutes
[Musique]
la crise du côté de 19 à semble-t-il
mise en lumière les pères mondialisation
et les contraintes qui vont avec
démondialiser pas sur un coup de
baguette magique ça coûte cher de
relocaliser il faut aussi changer ce
pourquoi les entreprises sont partis il
ya de grandes façon de le voir et qui
implique des stratégies qui sont
complètement différentes
vous pouvez essayer de refaire venir de
la vieille industrie qui a disparu ou
des secteurs qui ont disparu mais s'ils
ont disparu il ya une vue il ya une
bonne raison
l'autre façon de voir c'est de savoir
quels sont les nouveaux secteurs
auxquels sont les secteurs l'avenir
qu'on peut arriver à conserver chez nous
si un jour on veut re localiser et bien
il faut déjà empêché les cerveaux de
partir ou en tous cas lors donner des
moyens pour qu'ils aient envie de rester
bienvenue à novossibirsk
nous sommes au bord de la volga le plus
long fleuve d'europe nous sommes à chez
vox harry allons faire connaissance
vous avez choisi le jour à bagdad alors
je suis arrivé en 2005 pour étudier
dernière fois celle en profiter en 2011
elle ne demande pas un petit peu non ah
oui et c'est tous les fromages tous les
soucis sont toutes les les croissants la
pâtisserie traits de caractère des
russes qui te plaît l'amitié les gens
les gens très stylée les français ne le
savent pas je ne pensais jamais de ma
vie faire de la plongée autonomie vous
pouvez me souhaiter bon courage
à très bientôt sur arte france
[Musique]
la gauche aujourd'hui et surtout faible
parce qu'elle a déçu parce qu'elle n'a
pas répondu aux attentes et aux espoirs
qui étaient placés en elle pour vous
c'est quoi finalement
l'enjeu principal les législatives où la
présidentielle nous souhaitons parler
avant tout à toutes celles et ceux qui
n'y croient plus qu'ils s'abstiennent
aujourd'hui voyez il ya énormément de
français aujourd'hui qu'ils ne veulent
plus aller voter puisque vous parlez de
ce nouveau souffle à gauche
cela s'inscrit dans l'eure dans un
rassemblement on a du mal à comprendre
l'idée d'une candidature communiste je
ne souhaite pas que dès maintenant on
nous dise et bien vous n'avez pas le
droit de présenter votre candidature de
quel droit aujourd'hui on pourrait dire
ça laissez les français décider oui le
parti communiste français souhaitent
pouvoir incarner l'alternative le
changement l'espoir
tous les jours des groupes de pression
remettent en cause notre pays au niveau
de son histoire et ne s'intéresse qu'au
présent pour eux la souveraineté
nationale ou populaire est inacceptable
car assimilés aux régimes dictatoriaux
ou à une vision dépassée de l'intérêt
national
d'un autre côté des élites nous
encourage à abandonner l'idée de nation
française pour nous rallier à une europe
paré de toutes les vertus
malheureusement l'expérience montre que
si l'un des acteurs choisi de faire
cavalier seul en instaurant par exemple
des taxes ou protectionniste ou en
mettant en place des lois dissymétrique
la mondialisation se révèle un piège
pour tous les autres il faut avoir le
courage